open work session and recess it until he
gets here thank
you
okay uh reopen I
guess HP
1183 and uh
so uh sponsor you weren't able to make
the
hearing but um this is a subcommittee so
we're really not going to be taking
testimony per se but I guess I'd like to
hear your rationale
why we should pass this
when I've heard concerns that they U
that some people up in the north country
are very worried about American
companies are buying Forest land for the
purpose of solar or get for energy
credits whatever and they're not
logging so should we be doing that to
stopping that
too okay so let me for the record my
name is Ted Gorski I represent Hillsboro
District 2 uh which is Bedford New
Hampshire let me
first and provide you some information
on this and come back to your
question this particular bill right now
China owns roughly 380,000 acres of land
in the
US and the
USDA
is responsible for getting uh reporting
requirements after 90 days after a
transaction is done but have no
authority to investigate these
transactions the USDA cannot rely ably
report information to where and how much
agricultural land is held by Foreign
entities this was a report recently that
they gave to
Congress AAL Hayes who is the director
of National
Intelligence stated recently that quote
the Communist CH Chinese party
represents a leading threat to our
national
security this whole purpose of this bill
is to
protect New Hampshire farmlands protect
New Hampshire families because the
ultimate goal one potential motivation
is for the CCP to buy
Farmland harvest the
crops send them to
China also their Al potential ultimate
goal is to take control of the food
supply chain and I recently had a couple
of auto dealers that I spoke with who
had an issue
uh last year getting chips for vehicles
and they basically told me that Ted If
you walked into my dealership
today you cannot I cannot give you a new
C for approximately four to six months
and that was because the common Chinese
party really owned the chip
Market we cannot allow that to happen to
our
farmlands this has to we have to protect
our farmlands and and our critical
infrastructure
entities so uh Mr chairman if you can
repeat your question regarding the
logging okay but I would first tell you
that your these auto dealers are
confused um the chips are coming from
Taiwan not the People's Republic of
China okay second of all um the question
was
basically um if if
uh terms of the we we haven't had any
reports that the Chinese are buying any
land in New Hampshire true and and we
actually have a concern about these
other companies who are buying land in
Hampshire and and actually being a
disservice to our state's
economy and so the problem is not
Chinese the problem is
Americans so
why would we want to pass this
legislation M when we're not even
addressing the real problem in the state
first of all this is this particular
bill is to kind of be ahead of what's
happening because chines because the CCP
is not buying Farmland right now doesn't
mean that they will not there are 15
states that already passed legislation
which protects the farmlands and
critical entities in our in their states
so we can't put our head in the sand and
say okay because they haven't purchased
any here now meaning that it never will
happen we should be ahead of the game to
protect the farmlands in this
state and in regards to your question on
the logging and the other critic the
American companies this particular bill
was more focusing on foreign entities
not necessarily us
companies in the
state well I just say personally I'm not
big on uh in the immortal words of uh a
former chairman of the finance committee
um prophylactic
legislation um generally we want to put
legislation we want to solve a problem
that's happening not something that
could happen or potentially happen
because if we did that we would be
cluttering the law books with lots and
lots of statutes which in the land that
Live Free or Die that seems to be an
anathema so I personally um not too
interested in passing this bill but I am
certainly uh willing to interim study it
and hold it so that uh if there at some
point in time we did find that there
somebody you know that this was going to
be a problem in the state at least we
would have a vehicle in which we could
address the problem with I think Mr
chairman I think what's important is we
have a conversation about this exactly
to make sure that we uh protect our our
assets here in the state by interim
setting it we would have that same
effect
representative
spear uh this this may be a would you
believe but it may be a question well
yeah we're not we're not this is not a
hearing so this is all right then I can
say would you believe if I want to you
don't even have to bother saying it you
can say whatever you want this you're
actually entitled to your opinion now
yeah
finally uh having come from New York and
lived in New York City a lot of my
original part of my
life uh at one point or another the
Chinese have own the Empire State
Building Arab countries have owned the
Empire State Building as other Asian
countries India everybody's owned the
Empire State Building and it was the end
of the world every single time they
owned it everybody was getting oh my God
they're going to tear it apart they're
going to do this and nothing ever happen
so I kind of agree with you unless we
see where this is
going I I don't I've seen things happen
in the past where it didn't happen just
because someone thought it might happen
this is land they can't take it away and
at any time the United States can find
reasons
to you know kind of cancel out the the
sale for whatever legal reasons they can
come up with so I I don't know I'm I'm
kind of like with you on this I I don't
think we should be uh acting
prophylactically as you put
it yes representative grassing yeah I I
I I agree with you as well I think that
one of the things is here is is that you
know reacting just to the Chinese coming
in and taking things is is not what we
should be looking at I think we have I
mean there are examples of like Saudi
Arabia buying land in out in the west to
plant alela draining all the water
resources and then taking that alela and
exporting it back to their country uh
and maybe what we need to do is you know
that this bill isn't the correct thing
to do but maybe what we need is some
sort of registry that the Attorney
General would have to be able to and and
a time frame before any of our land is
swn to a foreign any foreign country um
over a certain size um that they need
that it needs to be reviewed um you know
that would be maybe be able to address
the concern that these folks here have
but um it's going to need a lot of work
this is not the
bill okay any other comments yes
representative
Walsh uh personally my opinion I think
there's a big difference between a bill
building and farmland you know we need
to keep farmland and uh
as I think that's that's a different
level of importance versus a building so
that's that's just my humble opinion
yeah but we're doing a lousy job of
keeping Farmland in here in New
Hampshire remember in
Hammond did just uh my thoughts on the
matter I think it's useful to have this
conversation
uh China's our number one Global
adversary they're a communist country
they basically are behind every company
every Chinese company has a communist
cell within the company um there's
recent news
reports that in Maine uh Chinese
companies are buying Farmland to grow
illicit marijuana that's common
knowledge at this point I think and also
there's reports that they're buying
Farmland near uh military bases in the
country so we don't want to put our head
in the sand and think that this isn't an
issue um maybe this bill needs work or
maybe the conversation needs to continue
but I I thank the member for bringing
this legislation
forward
okay any other comments let's see who
who do we have here that's from the
committee in the sub commmittee only
half
of so you
myself
Cole Co
and here with grass SE actually because
he he's I've taken Sean
SP
right okay
so you're this a second year so so uh we
don't have retain anymore now we have
interim
study
so an interim study would mean that uh
we would you know meet again um next you
know by next fall in the fall and we
would then discuss you know where what
we think about this bill and at that
point um you either recommend or not
recommend for future
legislation and then the bill then the
bill could be reintroduced in the next
bium M Mr chairman another option the
committee has as well is have an ad hoc
committee um if we to report this as itl
an ad hoc committee could look take a
look at a much broader subject as far as
our agricultural I I generally don't
like to do that okay okay then I just to
me the interim study I don't know if you
there when we did that uh issue of study
committees yep and way what I testify to
to the whole all the legislators is that
the in the Commerce Committee we like we
like inim study because interim study
means we have the bill it's in our
possession and we can frankly we can
have a ing on it at any time not not
many committees do that that's problem
that that is true that not many
committees do that but we we guarantee
we definitely will meet you know we'll
meet on by September we would meet and
discuss what has happened in the
meantime thank you
so okay so I'd like to make a motion of
inter room study anybody willing to
second that motion second the
motion representative Cole seconds the
motion
and represent taxon here so we're we're
Chuck full of Republicans here we're not
really only have one of
them you're done uh so no we already
have a second I was just saying that I
assume I assume you want to
replace your your missing Dems here
we're not voting today no no this is
just for the subcommittee we're not
voting today you're not worried about it
okay okay all right so uh the pending
motion is inter room study uh any
discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
please say I I those
opposed oh because you want to kill
it
okay gotcha okay that's right in
represent grassy which way would you
vote you would you would vote no okay so
the pending vote is is 4 to two here oh
Herbert well but he wasn't here when the
question was put I have all the ANS in
that's what I'm afraid
of thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman thank you
committee
okay no
four let you get the five I get
four four to two
right yeah
okay all right up next uh relative to
single use disposable plastic foot food
wear
accessories all right uh anybody have
some opinions I don't even have my bills
here have some opinions on this
bill good
representative spear I'm sure you must
have an opinion about this
bill I mean it's a good idea we should
probably do this except that we have the
past bill coming up that's going to ban
this stuff all together so
I'm not sure where to where to take
this no not really
uh no you're
right let's do it no we're not GNA do
that yeah it's my opinion that's the
wrong
[Laughter]
answer scient no it isn't because the
next bill will
oh
yes representative Bros I just was
reading your your text message to me
that I'd be
late um I actually GNA say something
that may surprise coming from um
somebody from my party but I actually
think that you know we keep having the
single use bills over and over and I
actually think it might be more
effective for stores to band together
and have a marketing program that we
don't have disposable utens
I think that you know I think this you
know we we these have failed over and
over again you know and I I see this as
kind of being analogous to the GMOs
where they did a marketing you know
there's a label on it no GMOs and a lot
of consumers look for that and for me if
I and I'm I'm actually becoming much
more conscious where I eat at lunchtime
because I don't want the plastic so if a
store had that on their store we don't
have disposable um food wear I I'd
probably go there more often
it's education yeah does that surprise
you um no because I think you're a very
level-headed person
sometimes and I think you're absolutely
right that that you know there's you
know there this you would think that a
an establishment would want to have a
sign and say if you don't need the all
this accruement please say no thank you
and and some are actually doing it I
mean I went to REI and I bought a bunch
of stuff and they said we don't have
bags which you know I thought was great
you know I didn't know I was going to
get all my stuff out and they didn't
have carts but you know I I thought that
was great that they did that you know
right
yep I mean I I've always been a big
believer and I think even I've been
thinking about this past bill that we
really want to empower the
consumer um because I just saw one of
the recommendations was just to remove
the the labeling require requirements
and I'm actually the complete opposite I
labeling is important that that that if
consumers I mean the biggest problem we
have with Pas is the consumers are
oblivious to it um but that that uh if
if you know if we did have like you said
the M you know the um modified the mg
what it was GMOs GMOs genetically
modified and I and I see it on cans all
the time and I've always wondered how
many people really say you know no thank
you and put it back on the
Shelf you because I think that that's
that is the right answer you know that
that you know empower the consumer to
say okay no I don't want that stuff but
I also still think in terms of the P has
Bill which is the Clearing House which
is that companies have got to be more
forthcoming
about the fact that it h whether it has
it or not because we can't where it's
hard especially when if we're going to
try to ban the food packaging it's hard
to know whether that's GMO or not I mean
not GMO excuse me but it's p fast or not
you know that packaging it looks a
little mysterious looks a little
suspicious but we don't know you know
what you know what's really in there and
that and that should be an obligation of
the the merchant to
notify so um I mean how strongly are you
demon you know obviously you feel like
that you want interim study I mean you
kill this build then not even interim
study yeah I'll go along with what you
said it made made a lot of sense okay so
which is it interim study or or you want
to kill it I'd like to see it I'd like
to see it go to interim study because I
think there are certainly some other
options uh for single use instead of
plastic and uh there are um restaurants
and other companies that are using non
um oilbased or non-plastic based um
recyclable materials uh that or
compostable materials that could be used
instead and I think if we take a look at
this and maybe get it down to where we
can refine it to um that that we direct
people or direct or try to encourage
companies to not use plastic uh
materials throwaways but to use
compostable or uh non-plastic materials
instead so I'd like to inter and study
it okay yeah representative Amon yeah
I'll just give my Sense on this um to to
me this kind of uh triggers the idea
that uh it's a nanny State bill that
we're micromanaging what people can and
can't do um I put this up there with
banning plastic straws banning plastic
bags um but if there's a market-based
approach I think we heard that in our
testimony that there's a um there's a
group that goes around to restaurants
and uh encourages them to to not do this
and I mean doesn't mean it's a bad idea
I just don't like the idea of the
government Banning a common thing that
we all probably have in our kitchen
drawer at home so um Banning abortion
it's a whole different
subject if you want to go there we can
but we probably
shouldn't okay actually I think that
when you think about it because we also
have the the bottle
Bill and in the bottle Bill we did
um we've got the Private Industry to you
know get create the blue bags and and
and really make an awareness for people
um you I think the blue bag is an
awesome awareness when you drive by and
you see that and you see all the how big
stuff full of stuff in there it makes
you aware that you know how much is is
ending up on the side of the roads
um so I I think that that if you when in
general we if we use these these bills
as a vehicle to try try to impress upon
um the merchants and markets and and
help uh somehow help help them educate
the consumer how important it is you
know to to you know don't don't take
that plastic if you don't need
it uh I don't know whether the blue bags
have past in them that's a good
question
well but again this is where I'm saying
that that really what we really want
with the p is you know is is in terms of
because I'm I'm a little concerned how
we're going to
enforce the past bill but that if if if
the issue comes down to is if you got p
in it you need to let people know it
should be stamped right on on anything
that has p in it we should know that it
has p in it if we're going to talk about
P I really think we're going to have to
we're not really talking about because
uh representative eel is here no I
understand but all General it's all
getting B past is a public health issue
it's different I mean people are getting
sick from past so I think it's a a real
different issue than these disposable
things right
okay so um I'm I'm okay with interim
study to Simply you know because and
just for the public to understand uh the
way Commerce operates and uh under under
um my leadership this past uh session
which is that um I don't want to have a
bill go to the floor
1010 I I just don't think that that's a
good uh precedent that um it it's a
matter of who shows up that day whether
a bill becomes law you know goes forward
or not it just it's uh you know to me uh
whether the voters knew what they were
doing or not knowing what they're doing
at the end of the day the fact that
we're 1010 means that that we only
really want to pass things that we we
have a strong majority in support of and
that that sending something to 1010 is
is maybe politically you know feel you
know that you know that okay let's have
the floor fight but I just don't I just
don't like doing that okay but just to
clarify that we will go to the floor
when we are cockus when we feel strongly
about it even if it is 101 I I hear that
you will hold out on that but I would be
begging you not to do that and that
let's let's just send these bills to
study and and and hope for the next
legislative session we're where you can
have a firmer uh majority one way or the
other we we don't want you to demean
Yourself by begging please well I do I I
can beg I'm just saying let's not do
that I think the fact well I'm just
saying that that may not happen there
you know it's when we feel strongly
about something we're going to go to the
mat I don't think it's going to be often
right Mr chair but I think it may happen
but then is a flawed bill that you're
sending to the floor at that time at
that point that's your opinion yeah
that's your opinion in my opinion yeah
I've been doing this 30 plus years I
think a bill that goes to the floor at
1010 is a flawed bill it's fundamentally
flawed because it doesn't have that
consensus that a committee's the whole
purpose of the committee is to find a
consensus to what makes a bill but some
bills are also politically motivated we
have to acknowledge that
uh I I'm trying I I I truly believe that
this committee should not be be move by
just pure policy oh I agree I agree
anyway we should and that's where that's
where I'm coming from this
commes well as a relative newcomer to
this operation I would like to and
therefore what I feel as an outsider I
believe you're both correct I believe
both sides will go to the floor and
we've seen I've certainly seen that in
my time here when you really believe
it's the right thing and I think that's
what you should do because the goal of
going to the floor is to sway votes on
the other side I also believe that
chairman Hunt is correct that really the
goal is to work the bills through
committee and come up with a consensus
and there are lit we could all come up
with a hundred answers of things that
are never going to come to a consensus
and that's where you just have to go
Slug It Out but for my part I'm happy to
send it to interim
study because that does give us that
we've seen bills in this last session
you know where you go wow it died before
so I agree I respect the position of the
Democrats to say we will go to the floor
the Republicans will certainly go to the
floor on those things that we disagree
with on and that is what still makes
America great yep and I want to say that
this I mean the reason I like serving on
this committee so much is that we agree
on a lot you you know I think we've
agreed on like up to 90 95% so you know
it's not like we're running up to to
challenge bills and I would say it's
because we're working it out in
committee yeah that's we're supposed to
do y so you know and I and I would
remind you we just the previous Bill we
just inter room studied it okay and
that's considered a partisan you know
Bill
right okay so
uh representative
uh okay so now no right now I'm I'm
proposing interim study second and
representative grassy uh seconds my
motion of interim study on 1207 is there
any discussion on the motion all those
in favor please say I I those opposed
I okay was that it was it yes is that a
no that he has a no he's a no to the
motion of interim study so that would be
5 to
one
okay all right next up 12:32 prohibiting
the state or local governments from
using Central Bank digital
currency so where where are we with this
bill keyth
do I even have to raise my
hand I assume you were opposed to it you
would like to see it call legitimate
reasons why okay but let's let's hear
what Keith that's all right so we
already have a bill that's in an study
on this very topic um I know
representative and I representative
Spears and I uh disagree on whether or
not this is a potential threat to the
Liberties of people in our state I think
it is a uh
a serious threat potentially
now will it be implemented I I can't
tell you that so this may be a
prophylactic uh bill but I I appreciate
that Representatives bring these bills
forward so that we can at least have a
discussion about it get educated about
it and understand that a central bank
digital currency could potentially
eliminate private banking potentially if
it's if it's a retail version yes the
banking Association is concerned about
that I've talked to them directly it
could also expose all of our
transactions to
government uh
surveillance and it could
also allow the government to expire
money that we have prevent us from
purchasing certain things that aren't
politically
correct it's a it's a tool for
surveillance if it becomes implemented
here uh China's already working on it
we've looked at the Atlantic Council I
know representative Spears you and I
have both referenced that and that more
than several dozen countries are looking
into this um
so I think it's a concern that we should
continue to pay attention to but I don't
think we're ready to legislate that's
that's my
opinion I I agree with in part with what
you're
saying but uh one of the problems I have
is that at the hearing some information
was presented that was flat out
Incorrect and I have a problem with that
kind of thing and and as you say we have
had an inum A bill on inum study and
then by goodness I studied
it and I even wrote to the Federal
Reserve and I asked them what are you
looking at I mean in terms of what this
thing is going to do and one of the
things they say that they they do not
have the ability to deal with the public
they're not even allowed to based on the
uh Federal Reserve
Act so they they view it as being Bank
as being Accounts at Banks where the
wallets are like actually kept in a bank
and the bank is the
intermediary and they gave a bunch of
rules of what people should be looking
at when they give their opinion on this
and that's one of the rules that they
have that they look at it the Federal
Reserve cannot deal with the public and
so they want Banks to act as
intermediaries so they're not there's
not a big rush to put Banks out of the
business but one of the things we have
to be aware of is that 88% of the entire
world's Reserve currency is the US
dollar and it is because we it is
because we are under a rule of law the
United States doesn't go willy-nilly and
cancel accounts or we going to lose the
biggest and best export that we have
which is the US dollar so the fear that
they're going to start putting
timestamps on the money is one that I
would have to put in the back burner
just because China is doing it doesn't
mean we're going to do it they have also
said that
they're among the rules that they have
is privacy protected consumer privacy
intermediated the money must be
transferable uh it has to be able to
prevent Financial
crimes and it has to be identity
verified so that we don't end up funding
terrorism and all kinds of of other
things that are going on they've gotten
back 5,600 Pages as I've mentioned
before of uh of people's opinions and
organization opinions of what this
should look like they don't know what it
should look like they're evaluating
everybody's opinion so we don't know yet
what we're looking like so I think in
light of what you're saying uh
representative Amman is that we're not
ready to legislate on this yet but I
will say and I have to say this at the
the meeting it at the hearing it was
presented that Texas had passed a law
outlawing Federal outlawing uh Central
Bank digital currency they did not what
some states are doing is passing
resolutions that they don't like it and
that's what Texas did actually it never
even got out of that out of Texas it
never got signed there's about four
states that are doing that or attempting
to do that because the fact of the
matter is it is against the Constitution
like it or not it is unconstitutional
which means that it ever actually
happened you're in for a lawsuit and
you're in for a fight is that a fight we
really want when you consider that one
third of our income of the state's incom
comes from the federal government that's
not a fight we want they've also said in
their writings that it is
interchangeable with paper money and it
is interchangeable with any other kind
of currency electronic representation of
the dollar that we have it's an addition
to it isn't a substitution of it's
optional and that's one of that's the
rules that they have So based on that
unless we see something
different just back burner it again
another one or just we already have one
back bur it just cancel it already itl
it okay representating
Amon I I appreciate our sparring on this
issue and we're kind of coming to the
same conclusion which is fun but um one
area that I differ with you
representative Spears is I have a little
less trust for the federal government
having a our best interests in in mind
long term so um our job is to steer the
ship of state and in our federal system
the states have a say we don't have to
just defer to whatever the federal
government's going to do and some states
like Florida is definitely the first one
uh outlawed a central bank digital
currency it's become a national issue I
don't know if you've paid attention
recently but the front runner of the
Republican party just said he's never
going to allow it so maybe we have to
hope that gets in I don't
know I'm I'm just making a joke um but
um I think uh this issue should be kept
on the on the burner and if we have two
bills that it's we're doubly paying
attention to it um now in this committee
uh last year we amended the uccc article
12 statute to exempt the definition of
money to take a potential Central Bank
digital currency applying to the
definition of money we modified that
bill so that you know we're not
explicitly allowing it we're we're going
to wait and see what it looks like but I
I agree with that but I am worried about
it I think that I think it is very
important to indicate that on that bill
and I have a copy of it if you'd like to
see it on the floridaa bill that
outlawed it it says in the physical note
that they understand it's
unconstitutional and the damage to the
state is
undefinable they understand that that
what they're doing could be very bad for
the
state I the one that in Alabama which
also outlawed it which this this bill by
the way looks like a almost an exact
copy of the one from
Alabama and if we're going to say
something political we really shouldn't
be looking at Alabama as an example of a
good now
now hey look we started it we are being
respectful of every state okay but in
Alabama they said there would be no
impact and that's ridiculous of course
there is going to be an impact if
nothing else is going to be a lawsuit
so I think it's it based on that we have
to move very
carefully so uh over the years we've
always had the expression of not ready
for prime
time so I think most of these bills are
not ready for prime time and then
interim study is always the right answer
okay fre speech over
here yes I'm so
sorry I I do so
you and you have something important to
say on this matter so please turn on
your microphone the uh speak to the
microphone there
are it's not ready for prime time I
agree with that there you go but what I
want to point out is that
uh in the in the larger context in the
political
context the opposition
is primarily aimed at distrust
distrusting the uh federal government
and and the Federal Reserve and anything
in their uh in in that combination so as
a result the the uh the constant the
constant thing I hear is well I can do
this here in the state
and and there's a supremacy clause and
and it's they just say I don't really
care because I'm I'm here so New
Hampshire can do whatever it wants Texas
can do whatever it wants Florida can do
whatever it wants Alabama can do
whatever it wants and that really worked
with the Articles of the Confederation
which lasted 12
years so you need a good strong national
government and we need to trust it and
and if we want to go after it we have to
have a good reason now the reason
I'm susp suspectful suspicious
suspicious is the fact that uh the
federal government doesn't really know
what to do with the idea of digital
currency they really don't they're stuck
and and uh well this say state or local
by the way well it's well the problem is
it's uh it's the federal government's
job it's congress's job in this Arena
and it's not our job to uh work work
with the currency you know or what could
be an alternate currency which is I
think in the going to we're going to
have to discuss it but the fact of the
matter is um one of the threats of uh
being a Libertarian in is that you don't
you don't
acknowledge uh that's that's kind of
refrain from going down that but it's
it's it's a common you will but let him
fin but it's an all it's an all
inclusive
narrative that that is it's an ideology
it's a movement maybe but but it it
defies the uh Constitution and and every
time I hear it I realize I'm I'm being
asked to uh devalue uh the federal
government or defund it or and and the
and and the complaint is always the same
it basically boils down to it's my
business and you keep taking those out
of it and that goes right to the
currency and this dollar the
representative Spears is absolutely
correct it is the anchor of the world's
currency the central banks and to um
move away from the dollar and and
somehow convince me that that's a good
idea from everything I've read that's a
very bad idea so um I'm just saying this
is the narrative you're going to hear
over and over and over again
unfortunately and and uh you have to be
aware of the motivation respons so I you
know I I've read a lot
about I've read a lot about the politics
and and the and the ideologies of
various factions and they're all have
their own reasons for doing what they're
doing but the fact of the matter
is we went we went through this uh in
order to get a constitution and I don't
want to uh you know do it again and
that's what we're being asked to do too
many times just okay um representative
an i' like to respond first if you don't
uh you didn't say my name but I think I
was included in the uh the group that
you were talking about oh you're first
teamer all right um so I'd like to
respond uh first you mentioned the
supremacy clause and we hear people say
the supremacy Clause that doesn't mean
the federal government can do whatever
it wants the supremacy clause only
applies to the powers enumerated in the
Constitution the 10th Amendment says all
other powers are delegated to the states
New Hampshire is a state so if you want
to be constitutionally literate when you
say the supremacy clause it should apply
to something that's actually in the
Constitution so respectfully the money
is money specifically is currency is
specifically Al enumerated in the
Constitution
okay so representative grassy I I think
one thing that people are overlooking
here and one comment was says you know
that this is going on in China China is
looking at this and there's a reason I
mean if you put 100 economists in room
you're going to get a 100 different
opinions but one thing that we're
looking at on the world stage right now
on the world market with the dollar
being the Supreme world currency is
China is looking at using this to
supplant the dollar because this is how
you you are able to have intern Trade It
enhances international trade and if we
shut ourselves off from a central bank
digital currency it's not for individual
indiv people basically China is looking
this as a way to Conor the market on
world trade and to supplant the dollar
as the reserve currency of the of the
world and you know we we just can't shut
it off so I I I would say iail this um
you know there there's this is a much
bigger thing than little New
Hampshire so what is the bill that we
have already what what's
the on this subject matter it would uh
ban any any uh currency that uh doesn't
respect privacy rights I think that's
how it oh that's how it's written
protect was wasn't like El Salvador or
something
or didn't they decide to go with the
currency or so that's that's El Salvador
made Bitcoin legal tender along with so
would that be but that's that's a that's
like
different it's related but different
right okay well I'll just throw a
curveball into everybody I think the uh
the bill establishing a state bullion
depository sort of sounds like digital
currency to me because you're not going
to go around trading gold with people
you're going to be trading a digital
device so so no well I understand it's a
different bill but that's why I think
all these bills should be interim
studied okay uh can I ask a question
about that we already have one on
interim study how many do we need uh the
idea of interim study is because all of
them are in this Comm this subc
commmittee so that means when this
subcommittee meets with these issues
they they can talk about any one of
these bills and they're free to it's a
makes it an open conversation about any
any and all subject matters would be
available to the subcommittee I I think
I have to to agree here with the
representative I think that you know I
mean you can have all of these bills but
this one here I think is different I
think you know having personal privacy
and currency is something that we should
we should look at this is dealing with
something that is far beyond the state
of New Hampshire and I think we should
stay you know this is this is just not
one that is anywhere near Prime
Time
right well this kill it is again if it
if it comes down to 1010 we're going to
to to the floor and whether we're going
to kill it or interim study it like we
did I mean come on that's why waste
everybody's time on the house floor with
something like that let's just interim
study it and know that that this bill
probably will never have the deled day
but at least we can always talk about it
and have the committee has the vehicle
to talk about
please try try me out on this is I I
I've supported you on other ones I
seconded your last one you're not going
to get me as a second on this
one all right okay anybody like to make
a motion on 12:32 move to
itl well
it's let's let's interim study it well
don't you
think okay I'll make the motion of
interim study we got we got a motion on
the full I the chair I can decide
whether I accept a motion or
not since always a chair has a right all
right if you want to have an in itl
motion that's fine so who made the
motion grassy and it's seconded
by
Saxon okay so so you're not seconding
your motion and then you might not
necessarily Vote for This motion okay
representative spear made the motion
then okay okay I'm just telling you this
is the kind of thing we waste time this
is just waste of time to go into this
promotion
okay
again okay so um uh all those in favor
of itl itl please raise your hands one
two three
four all those opposed raise your
hand one two three
four guess on yeah okay thank you all
right motion is uh to
uh fails motion fails so the motion I I
just I was saying representative burough
I think you were representing muler but
m is here now so the motion fails all
those I moved to in inter room study no
no I move I move interim
study do I have a second to my motion
representative Axton I have a question
you may pose a question um we're dealing
with money here uh the dollar and we
have acknowledge that we have some
legislation in regards to crypto
which is aimed at becoming a a substance
how does this relate to the the somebody
here
is financially affected by this vote can
they vote ouch are you saying that
somebody has a conflict of interest in
you in state and local governments using
Central Bank digital currency no I'm
this is part and parcel of a larger if
if you think that somebody uh has a
conflict I would ask you to pull that
person aside and have them file a rule
16 filing well I don't know that that
they need to well exactly you that
saying you have that off offline you can
have that conversation with them I think
he's addressing it to me sure he is yeah
are you addressing it to me because I
can answer it no I I have no I have no
financial interest in a central bank
digital currency well that's
okay all
right okay the motion is inter room
interim study all those in favor of the
interim study motion please raise your
hand one two three four five six all the
supposed two two six to two all
right
Perfect all right nothing's easy today
is it okay
1406 relative to gender based pricing of
goods and services I'm sorry I I'm so
sorry but that's more than people that
are on the subcommittee No it's it's
it's a four and four oh it ended up four
and
four six and two makes four
eight you keep it under 10 I can I can
MTH works for
me okay gender based pricing of goods
and
services okay is there anybody who wants
to speak for this
bill
okay
good see who would like to carry forward
and write the uh uh the inexpedient the
legislate blur who would like to do that
we can decide that in EXA right okay
representative spear great moves um itl
yeah I will second the motion any
discussion on any being to
legislate see none all those in favor of
itl please raise your hand one two three
four four five six seven
eight perfect see there was one it was
easy
okay all right did you want to
vote no yeah sorry so what how would you
like to
vote yeah okay so change the votes to 7
to
one
okay
look at
me okay all right uh relative to
creating this New Hampshire container
deposit refund recycle and reuse system
bottle Bill all right who wants to speak
for the bottle
Bill represent
BRS yeah when I first heard the bill I
thought well this this might be a good
idea until I got an email from one of my
con constituents who has a bottle
distribution Bill 35 employees and um he
said that this bill could actually
increase uh it would give main mass and
Vermont A2 $240 Kate advantage and it
would also have an an impact on this
business um New Hampshire would end up
recycling bottles and cans from
neighboring states which I'm sure is
true a bottle with uh Point uh 05 value
in Maine would be worth as much as5 in
New Hampshire so they'd pay out as much
as5 for a deposit that they never
collected to begin with and um that
makes sense to me and um I'm certainly
not going to vote for a bill that's
going to hurt um a constituent's
business in that way great all right
anybody else want to speak for
it okay yeah Mr chairman yes represent
yeah I think it's something that you
know at worst case I think this is
something we should look at I mean if
we're going to be uh just killing it I
think that's would be responsible I
think we should interim study this um
it's certainly something that I think
that um you know many particularly on my
side uh have a lot of support for uh you
know this may not be the perfect bill
but uh to to just send it off into never
Neverland is uh probably not something
we should do I think we should take a
look at it maybe we can come out with a
come out with the perfect Bill next
time I say I think I think that's a good
idea just you know I hope that will
listen to people that it's going to
impact in the business Community
certainly and I and I don't disagree
with that that we should listen to the
business Community but we also have to
take a look at the amount of waste that
we're putting into our
landfills okay so the sponsor would like
to speak yet come on up and turn the mic
on turn the mic on so we can all hear
you went home okay can everybody hear me
I won't yell but um so I was a little
surprised to see as many people here
today so I apologize for not having as
many uh handouts regarding um a
addressing the the objections but I just
wanted to say a couple things first of
all I think
whenever we present legislation that is
going to have a a large change I mean
it's really a systems change that we're
we're talking about we're we're never
going to present a bill you know that's
going to be perfect um unless that
Bill's been worked on you know multiple
times beforehand so what I'm presenting
to you is what I think is a foundation I
mean I I think that the broad concepts
of the bill could work for New Hampshire
um but we need to be bringing
stakeholders together we need to be
bringing the industry together that was
one of the things I was hoping that we
could do before the bill was crafted uh
but the way the system works it just
doesn't allow you to to do that um you
know if they want to come in and talk
about it but but most of the time what
industry wants to do is they want to see
the bill first and then they want to you
know kind of massage it or if they're
really against it and Industry is
against it in this case they just want
to have it dismissed but I think you
know I mean the the statistics prove
over and over and over again that every
state that has a bottle Bill their
recycling rates are triple double to
Triple what our resp re recycling rates
are we have Recycling Industries that
are looking for recycled Goods that in
in higher quantities and in higher
qualities and um you know uh Redemption
programs will do that now you know I
mean when we're talking about recy
recycling goals you know I mean it's not
set in stone um you know I mean is is a
90% goal goal
achievable probably not maybe we should
be reducing that are the are the other
goals you know the annual goals you know
but but let's get industry together with
us let's talk it out and let's see if we
can craft a better bill and I would be
more than happy you know to be if you do
interim study it I'd be more than happy
to be the Workhorse on that make the
contact so we can get the right people
in the room and and we we hash it out
and see what we can come to
so Mr chairman yes um is this bill
modeled after any other State's bill I
mean it seems awfully long and I would
think it could be a much simpler Bill am
I incorrect yes you are incorrect okay
representative M mclair I have I mean
I've looked at the michig the reason I
settled on this bill uh this model or
this template was because I could
understand it okay you have other bills
you know older bills uh you know uh
Michigan was um 1978 you know and the
the way the money flows um is very
obtuse you know was hard to understand
it's very complicated in the most uh
most of the times they put the
government in charge a government agency
that's not the New Hampshire way so but
but to your point these bills are
complicated they have a lot of different
facets to it and that's why we really
need to be developing a partnership um
and and it doesn't need to be as
expansive we we need to start someplace
oh oh the other thing I wanted to
mention and forgot about this uh it
should the uh Liquor Commission should
be Exempted at this point I never meant
to have The Liquor Commission included
uh but when we were talking about this I
frankly was thinking more in the line of
grocery stores but under the bill the
way it's written Now The Liquor
Commission would be included although I
think at some point they would be
perfect you know for some kind of
redemption system that's down the road
um we don't we don't want to complicate
things so so that's uh one of the things
I wanted you to think
about now how does that make any sense
you're going to
tell everybody in the state that you
know all the merchants they got to do it
and that the state is off the hook I'm
saying uh I'm saying they're off the
hook as a redemption
center for the moment but think of how
many bottles they're pushing out the
door representative hunt if you want to
include them and and have that part of
the study I'm I'm fine with it I'm
complete opposite I think that's a
classic example why this bill should not
ever be passed
why we should never have a bottle pill
in New Hampshire and because we too have
some skin in the game and know that we
don't want you know this is this is a
huge burden on the system we have a
great system now of getting you know
getting the trash picked up the side of
the roads which is the fundamental need
uh in terms of recycling I mean yeah I'm
you can't get anybody who's more wants
to recycle than me you I mean
I go into it but I think aluminum should
always be recycled everybody should be
saving their recy aluminum I think
that's a great idea but but but at this
time it's it's like it's it's an age
gone by it's a recycling rate is
23% okay and and the only state in New
England that's lower than that is Rhode
Island it's 19% and they don't have a
bottle Bill Maine is
65% I think Massachusetts is 40 I think
Vermont is
44 okay um and yeah so so I mean I I
think it's nice but unless we put
mechanisms in place that make it
convenient and convenient for them and
also everybody goes to the grocery store
every week people in the North Country
go go to the transfer station we will
make it convenient for them to do it no
but it's not convenient I mean I mean if
convenience was true then they wouldn't
have to have signs there don't forget to
bring in your your shopping bags okay we
all forget to bring our shopping bags
all right well not all if I can't
remember to bring my shopping bag why am
I going to remember to bring my my my
recyclables well right now the
recyclables you know I I right now take
my recyclable you know when I go to the
you know get to the dump you know so
that's my point and your dump can have a
recycle center there and so instead of
putting them in the bin to recycle you
put it in want pay 30 cents on my
six-pack or 60 cents I know you're going
and you're going to allow somebody to
make interest on that 60 cents for a
week no I
no oh listen I can't convert you and I
in this system in this system you have
the option you have the option to
recycle you have the option to throw it
in your trash and have it go in the
landfill that's your choice okay so
we're not forcing you to do anything no
you're forcing me to pay more at the
time I'm buying it represent am thank
you Mr chair um just thinking about this
issue so in in New Boston the town I
live in we have a recycling very fine
grained recycling in our town dump so we
have to separate the plastic by the
Numbers uh and uh the enforcement is
very strict if you uh get my drift we
have a dumpster n Nazi too I I was
he rips the bags open right there in
front of you when D hi Jerry um so my
question is we our town funds our um our
transfer station based on recycling fees
and if the state had had a uh you know a
Statewide program would that make it
harder for us to fund our transfer
station uh no because in this bill um
there there is a way to um what's the
pay back transfer stations okay so so if
you look at one of the things that I
tried very hard to look at is um making
sure that that everybody got a little
bit now you know I mean there might be
some towns where they the recycling
rates are really high for like aluminum
okay and they might um you know so they
might lose Revenue there but I can tell
you every transfer station that I've
talked to one of the big issues is glass
okay because glass is heavy so per
tonnage you're paying a lot for it uh so
anything that they might make on say
aluminum you know they're going to be
losing on cardboard and plastic and and
and glass um they can also become a
Redemption Center okay so and and in
this bill uh if you choose to become a
redemption center it's an organization
uh the industry pays for it so so right
now we're all paying for this stuff to
be carded away whether you know and and
I don't know any Town that's making
money on their landfills or on their on
their transfer stations I mean
everybody's paying for it so you know so
in in this case you would have set up a
producer respons uh a PR producer
responsibility
organization and it's their
responsibility to purchase install and
maintain reverse vending machines you
know in these location
and they also um reimburse the let's say
if it's a retail store or if it's um a
transfer station they also get
reimbursed for the footage that is being
taken up by the reverse vending machine
area and the as the pro gets more
efficient okay I mean you're always
going to have people who choose to throw
their you know bottles and cans out the
window okay and the 60 cents doesn't
mean as much as them to them as it means
to other people so you know so that
money will go back into the system okay
and and it defrays all of these costs
the other thing that's really important
is that the bill there's oversight on
the part of Dees but all of their costs
are paid um through the producer
responsibility organization so again
there's there's no cost to the taxpayers
where right now you know there's a huge
T cost to the taxpayers um because you
have Industries who are producing trash
you know I mean they they create a
product it becomes trash and we pick up
the bill for it and you know Industries
are beginning to understand this is not
new technology I mean they've been doing
this for years in uh Europe okay I mean
we have 10 states that are doing it now
um You Know It it's in my old home state
of Michigan and it's been in effect
since 1978 my you know my the people my
family back there it just becomes part
of your it becomes part of your routine
just like recycling is now no different
great thank you yeah represent
taxon so I need to put on my selectman's
hat this bill is a nightmare for a small
town and I don't want to burn up the
next 25 minutes on explain to everybody
in the room why and then arguing the
case I think we have the sponsor of the
bill has said she recognizes the bill is
flawed and I think the most appropriate
thing to do with the bill while I would
like to say itl it is send it to interim
study that's how that representative
taxon moves interim study right second
and we have a second by representative
grassy any discussion on the motion of
interim study see none all those in
favor please say I I those
supposed represent Herbert I didn't hear
from
youj okay eight to
Z all
right okay be
fast
good
morning to print out some documents for
the committee and I just need one of the
packets so here's my question what food
packaging
items today have pasas in
it
can't give you the specific one Mr chair
but there there are definitely some and
they're
progressiv outla I know that there
were bags and
that well not gonna read
this for the F
okay
so what we what we need to do is be
looking at the bill and how we're going
to amend it right and I just so I'm and
I'm ready and prepared to go very deeply
with you into that but I just before we
started um for the record my name is
Karen eel I represent marac district 7
um which is New London and Newbury
thanks so what is I wanted to share with
the committee just as a as a starting
point um the first thing is that um I
just provided to for for your uh
information I just provided to the chair
a copy of the complaint that new
Hampshire filed several years ago
against 3M uh to recoup uh losses for p
contamination in the state of New
Hampshire it was filed by Gordon
McDonald which as you know is uh
Governor sununu's attorney general
appointee at the time I provide that to
committee to just to show and you can
read in there the descriptions of why uh
we're seeking damages um I'm also going
to provide to the committee when we're
were done the most recent report from
the Department of Environmental Services
on the UR occurrence of past
contamination in New Hampshire it's very
widespread this was issued in December
of
2023 and I offer this um as further
evidence of why it's a smart move for
New Hampshire to start to turn off the
tap another thing I would I want to uh
share with you is and it should be in
the materials provided by representative
spear the national waste and recycling
Association has written um in support of
this bill it uh and as they say here the
New Hampshire chapter members operate in
every community and employ more than
2500 residents and they generate $150
million in state Pro uh payroll and
responsibility for $400 million in
Revenue um the support uh
includes um waste management cassella
and several other recycling um and waste
management organizations and I was able
to get um the members from New Hampshire
from the um NW and I'd be happy to
provide that to the
committee
um so the other thing and we'll discuss
this in Greater detail
um I wanted to make sure that the
committee uh checks out State actions on
P because the last time we were here we
discussed the across theboard past bands
that were in Maine and Minnesota what I
didn't know at the time honestly is that
there were many many other targeted
bands in the in the United States and
that we would not be going it alone
based on the items that I've selected uh
and identified for product bands and we
can talk about this um in more
detail um so I have some other things
here but we can go ahead and and dive
into the um and dive into the bill so I
have so many
papers um the first thing Mr shair and I
think you can have perhaps a deeper
conversation about um this issue with um
director whimet pursuant to your uh
request we did seek further information
on the issue of the Clearing House for
purposes of
notification um the
notification provision in the bill
starts on page four line
um and as I say i' I'd like to ask uh
the director to speak in more detail
about this but basically what what I
wanted to do is get on paper a letter
for the committee to look at that
described exactly what numo was thinking
about with respect to a clearing house
for reporting purposes and if we were to
participate in a CL in a Clearing House
it would be the
ic2 the numbers for creation of the
clearing house and for membership are
much less than what um the department
originally
thought however they're still um not
insubstantial so uh you can we can talk
in Greater detail about that but Mr
chair especially I I wanted to get this
for you all right down there on paper so
it wasn't a telephone tag or or whatever
I wanted you to see it
yourself um and the rest of the
committee so going to the notification
provision um which as I say starts on
page four line so my understand you
don't have an amendment for me for us
today I don't have uh no I didn't bring
in because I thought that we would be
discussing this and I'd be happy to
prepare an amendment for you based on I
mean I have I have a very clear idea of
of what an amendment would look at but I
thought it would be helpful for the
committee because it's not going to be a
lot of tweaking it's going to be a
decision there's a lot seven pages in
this current bill right and go for us to
go through this now it's not going to
take that long I swear to you okay so
the first thing I guess I but I also
want the department see I was looking
for the Department to be creating this
if if you would just bear with me for a
little bit Mr Mr chair here okay all
right I am here to discuss with you the
notification provision because I have
learned that
um aside from
Maine and there is really no other state
that has a notification provision like
this in their targeted band okay so
where is that in this bill that is on
page four line
and I
you know again I defer to the committee
but if it makes a difference to the
committee from an expense
standpoint um and from a burden to the
agency if we want to align with other
states that have targeted banss we could
completely remove the notification
requirement and that so this is all
Roman numeral four that is Roman numeral
through um page five line 11 so that's r
a numeral four yes okay okay so then
moving on to page five uh line
12 this is uh section five this is the
labeling requirement so if you go
through the industry
documentation um you will see that one
of their biggest objections to this bill
is the labeling requirement and that is
because this bill is a targeted ban of
very I of of a certain number of
consumer products if we do an across
theboard B uh across theboard labeling
requirement folks like the automobile
industry um the medical folks all sorts
of folks will have to uh engage in quite
a bit of labeling I believe that
labeling is really helpful
however I can also understand why it
creates huge uh complications for the
industry and I think that if we move
ahead with a ban um we could discuss
labeling in the future so if we remove
the labeling portion that would be Roman
numeral five which goes all the way to
page six line
11 now OS very helpfully
also named prohibitions Roman numeral 5
yeah I see that looks like they right
screwed up so uh this is another Roman
numeral right so on the um on the
subject of the product bands I would
refer to you again this state uh action
on past this is really helpful because
it identifies the products being banned
and the years when the bands are
effective so if you go through my list
there is virtually nothing on this list
that is not also on this um on the list
of targeted bands that have already been
um have already are are in the process
of taking
place um I would call out feminine
hygiene products in many cases they
include those in um personal care
products so um even though you see them
called out maybe separately on here it's
actually many more states have this um
dental floss and this is going to relate
to another uh discussion we're going to
have in a minute um dental floss believe
it or not is a medical device approved
by the
FDA and I'm going to propose that we
exclude products that are approved by
the FDA as medical devices and drugs um
from the
bill so that would mean that we'd remove
dental
floss the the item that's also affected
by an exclusion of FDA approved medical
uh devices is personal protective
equipment and I've been in communication
with uh several Industries representing
the medical folks and um they provided
me with uh language which I do have um
that I could provide to the committee
and that exclusion language would come
in later in the bill so the only other
thing I wanted to say about this um to
the committee
is I have upholstered furniture here as
number
10 there are several states that are
excluding textiles as a whole not
including
apparel we could
consider um removing dental floss and we
can also consider Florine treated
containers if you want to because that's
not a targeted band that would be in
effect before ours and it might be worth
considering replacing that with uh
textile articles because it has a huge
past load and it's a great concern to
the um to the waste management people
and I could provide language in that
regard so that's sort of what I have to
say about the product
ban I I think it's difficult to talk
about the product ban without um
referring the committee um and I'm sorry
I'm going backwards in the bill to the
definition
section um for
p which is
on uh page page three line
S so one of the most highly discussed
topics in all of this is the definition
of
pasas um we already have a definition of
pasas in the books um on behalf of
firefighters and firefighting foam and
if you look at that if you go on line
eight I would propose we conform our um
Bill to the statutes that we already
have in place and I would propose
removing or methylene carbon atom and
just conclude it with fully fluorinated
carbon I've discussed this with the
state toxology uh Jonathan patali the
most patient person on Earth and um this
actually makes the definition somewhat
narrower than the definition that I have
here and that definition will conform
with the definition that's used in all
these targeted bands and it will conform
with uh what we already have on our
state
statutes now I have to say here that the
industry and you span and the American
chemistry Council we've had really
really good conversations and we've
discussed
it they would like to narrow the
definition more more and the specific
concern is hfos which are refrigerants
and can be used for
propellant there is not a product that I
am targeting for a ban that includes
those items and I honestly don't see the
reason now for excluding hfos from our
definition I just and and if you want to
think about implementation of these
targeted bands ease for the agency um
also for
manufacturers um you know I just and
also just alignment with our own laws I
don't see the point in going to a more
complex um definition and you know if
you want to talk to the state toxology I
mean we've talked about this the concern
is really the issue of
hfos
um the simplest solution there is just
that after you have this definition you
then go on and say that at no time does
this include and then create that Lit
spot where you would say hfos you know I
mean we could do that or we that way
that way they would have warm fuzzies
that that the only way they would be
included is that we would have to repeal
that out of our statute well or we just
don't I mean Mr chair you and I will
disagree on that I just honestly don't
see the point at this point for
excluding them because I'm not targeting
anything that they're involved in and
clearly if if a product was going to be
added that included hfos it would take
legislation and it just wouldn't happen
without this uh legislator's um support
so you know chicken in the egg you know
one of the other yeah I mean it really
is and as I said before nobody else is
doing that literally nobody else is that
that I see here is doing
that okay okay so um so how does this
this law enforced how is this law
enforced well I'm going to ask my um the
the department person to come up here
and speak I I will say that
understanding uh more completely that
there's not a notification provision and
that all these states are really relying
on certific of compliance we've had to
think a little more you know we have to
think a little bit more about that but
it's a mechanism that's that's being
used um by other by other states and the
only other thing Mr chair I'm sorry that
I didn't mention this before um I gave
there's a couple of sheets there with a
with a press release the EPA um as
of uh May
2025 has put into place uh under TSA and
I'm not I don't know the acronym um a
reporting requirement for all uh P using
their definition and their definition
does exclude um hfos as I understand it
but it's a pretty um complex definition
and again I'm not sure that's something
that we would want to include um however
it's a reporting system that will be up
and running before our ban would
uh take
place uh good morning morning uh Mr
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is Mike winsat I serve as
director of the waste management
division for the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services uh
in answer to your question Mr chair
regarding uh how it would be enforced as
currently drafted this bill does provide
uh for one position appropriates funds
for a position at the department
I will tell you that um if if as
representative eelis testified and
suggested that the reporting or
notification requirements were removed
um um we believe that actually that
position would be in a better position
to do compliance monitoring and
enforcement I think the fact that as
we've learned you know relatively
recently about the more broader group of
states that have already got laws on the
books to implement targeted banss um I
think that the that that job gets easier
because the more states that have done
this the more likely it is that uh the
manufacturers will find a way to
manufacture products that that are
subject to the band that don't have
pasas uh but we believe that you know
consistent with the way we've looked at
other bands um a position that's in in
the law right now or that's appropriated
uh in this bill uh would uh would be in
a position to monitor do compliance
monitoring of specific products and take
action when uh when compliance problems
are identified
so humor me uh that means just
compliance person is going to go around
and grab a something off the shelf and
test it or go see whether it's on the
list on the of of through the Clearing
House it's it's possible that that that
is a way to do it I mean we in the in
our taxic toxics and packaging uh work
we have actually gone and when we've
become aware that there's a particular
product that may be suspect we've
actually purchased one and taken a
sample and and done a few small
enforcement actions with regard to that
and it's been effective uh but also
because other states are involved and
because we would likely um to the extent
that there were services or information
being provided by a Clearing House such
as ic2 we would likely be coordinating
and communicating with our colleagues in
the other states and then that of course
just m means makes everybody's costs and
and and and burden much lighter well I
guess yeah I'm interested in how do you
do a seasoned assist I mean that's not
normally a task you guys do too often ex
well so the inate stuff yeah as the bill
is crafted it does give us enforcement
Authority and um we do have uh in our um
in our laws the ability to enforce
through administrative orders and civil
um and criminal sanctions depending on
so how do you stop I mean do you have
John Hunt's rule of lure that I mean a
business is making a product we don't
license them right you don't license
anybody so how are you going to cease
and assist how are you going to shut
them
down it in the case of tux and packaging
we have uh reached out through the
Attorney General's office to that
manufacturer or to that to that seller
and then um basically it said you need
to fix this and if they don't fix it so
this would be a responsibility of the
Attorney General's office to then
enforce the order in the final analysis
it could be that way it's possible if if
the legislature saw fit to give
administrative finding authority to the
department it's something the department
could do without the assistance of the
AG but but you can't really if you don't
have them licensed right how do you who
do you find when you no we we we have
administrative F we not not that I'm
testifying saying that's how it should
go but if it were to go that way I just
want to help help me out understanding
that we we do have administrative fine
Authority for a number of our regulatory
programs and there are many for example
in our hazardous waste program we don't
license hazardous waste generators there
are hundreds of Manufacturers that
generate hazardous waste we don't issue
licenses to them or or permits necessar
neily but they are all subject to
specific requirements that are in our
rules and when those rules are violated
we we have a long history of of of
issuing administrative penalties
administrative fines to those with
respect to they don't pay the fine uh
then the AG's office would have uh the
authority to to uh to enforce civil okay
so that statute did we use that from the
Mercury statute the uh how do you how do
you enforce that how did you enforce the
Mercury thing to be honest I don't know
if we ever needed to take an enforcement
action through the um the Mercury
program that's not me saying it didn't
happen I honestly don't know whether we
did but I'm not aware of
any okay because so so we're going to
create a position that's going to cost
us 100 30,000 forever and
ever well nothing's forever but but
unless we Sunset it or repeal it right
well so yeah if there if a position is
created that that was targeted at doing
that then that's what we would do
obviously if we get to a point years out
where the bands are fully implemented it
might well be that a part-time position
or even no position at all create
position for
mercury
um I we may have at the time I I wasn't
I wasn't involved in the program at that
time but I there no position there was
no specific position to Mercury at this
present because it's a it's a light load
because it's been in place and it's been
effective okay so what we're hearing is
um we need to maybe look at that
definition of past take out the meth
methylene carbon atom and I'm suggesting
that we add in a room of an exemption
list to say these things it does not
include that way it gives those people
warm fuzzy so they don't use that excuse
to why we should be opposed to the bill
if we specifically wrote in them to who
they would be out I know you don't agree
with me but that's just how um I I it's
this committee sees a lot of bills like
this and we and the it's always the
exemption list when the exemption list
gets longer than the actual statute then
we know we've got a problem with the
bill itself but I'm assuming that there
aren't too many entities that want to
make sure they're exempt from
this um so there's the medical group and
then there's the um then there's the
pesticide
manufacturers so I so for the exclusion
language um that would be in the
exclusion section of the bill um I would
I'm I have language to exclude the FDA
uh approved items and fifra which
where's the exclusion list where's that
in here
um well it's not Roman numeral
5 yeah actually I wrote h under
five but it probably is a whole new it
really is should have been
six um it's the section that says if if
there's something uh subject to
regulation by the federal government
then it's exempt oh
[Music]
okay uh wait I feel like I'm closing in
on it Botto page bottom of page
two you can I mean if you want to just
tell I I believe the section you're
looking for is uh Roman 2 page uh I'm
sorry page three line 36 it would makes
sense it would be two yes okay sorry
about that CR from this section okay so
somewhere in there we need to have yep
and I and the other uh group that I'm
proposing to exclude uh the utilities
you'll recall were
concerned um about uh being considered
Manu ufacturers are incidentally adding
things when all they're doing is just
processing uh our waste waterer and our
so I have language um okay so that's
what we'll need for the next meeting is
we need that exemption exemption list
okay so public
utilities and what do we call these H
what do we call the well we'll have to
talk about that I I have to say Mr chair
I'm just going to strenuously um object
to the object to the inclusion of that
as an exemption
but I'm just telling you right well let
me put it this way if you have all these
other people exempt you know like what
makes them so special versus this one
product because it's FDA approved it's
it's pesticide approval and it's a and
it's a utility and again there's no
product that I'm proposing to ban that
includes hfos so I just don't see the
point uh it's um what was like belts and
suspenders is what I've heard that
expression used before all right
well I remember Ed Ed Butler using it
yeah so I guess if we just want to go
through this Mr chair um if I'm going to
prepare an amendment yeah
um
I'll I I'll propose to remove the
notification
provision exactly and that's a good
chunk yeah that's a good chunk yeah I
like that's great and and by the way uh
uh California actually vetoed a
reporting bill um because of the EPA
reporting requirements
so I think we're you know anyway I just
thought I forgot that's a good direction
to go then is that what you're saying
well I thought you'd like that well in
norn California I I just want to know
what products actually been banned I
just like since it's been on the books I
guess California just been on the books
right it just got well yeah but so I
want to know what's actually what came
out of it I I want to know something
that actually got fix this doesn't tell
you what actually got fixed okay so
California passed it well it depends on
when the effective dat I can food
packaging that's the one I care about
the most well and you can see the most
uh folks are that's what they banned
okay um I'm going to get rid of the
labeling requirement yes do you have any
uh stomach for moving up the band date
to 2027
I'm not asking the agency this
question uh I if that was their
recommendation then that's one I want to
stick with all right well they they
didn't these were sort of my dates no I
thought that was a a very reasonable
compromise offer gives the legislature
plenty of time to decide to so you like
2028 2028 is wonderful okay
um okay you only wish I would I'm I'm
removing d
floss okay yes got rid of that and then
I would like I mean how about this
Florin treat get rid of fluorinated
treated containers and add in the
textile articles because the the waste
people if you I mean I've given you a
lot of materials one of those charts say
one of the biggest what's the difference
between textiles and fabrics um well I
would go back to the definitions that
were used but
um a it's a broad category that includes
all kinds of things but apparel is
excluded So Pro probably Matts I don't
know Mr chair I got to look at that but
I swear to you I will figure it out by
the time I have the amendment for you
okay um and yeah I mean I think I think
that's basically it and you know I I
would just say that I know there's
concern about employees but you know
this is really an incredibly important
issue that we're facing in the state we
need to turn off the tap and you can't
make it happen if you don't have a
person to to work on it I mean honestly
I think what happened in Maine one of
the reasons they got in trouble is that
they only um you know they went as big
as they could go and they financed two
employees and it's just overwhelmed them
okay humor me and just put a sunset for
5 years say that again Sunset five years
no the bills effective 2028 let's have
that position Sunset after a certain
point five years and that point then
there going to be the discussion whether
that there's a NE necessary need to keep
it going forward are you say are you
saying the dees position the person oh
you have the statue still on the book
I'm not changing that but given the fact
that we don't actually have an employee
for
mercury well I mean there's another way
to approach it I suppose and just say
that the the have the department come
back and report on the necessity of the
employee before we Sunset it I mean it's
also a discussion that we can have at
the finance level as far as money is
concerned I just asking to put the
sunset in for five years so that I can
say to the to finance that I'm
comfortable with spending a half a
million dollars in the next five year
you know the five years beginning 2028
on this to enfor you know to make sure
this is enforced and after that point
they can so there's an employee and
there's a another appropriation yeah
yeah I see so you're talking about the
employee the two the 250 is a One-Shot
deal just to get things up and
running that was I'm looking down at the
methodology yeah and then and then I
assume because I've had bills before
where it has creates positions and I
just don't want to be accused of
creating a position that'll last forever
and ever I wouldn't want you accused of
that Mr
chair um okay so I'll initiate the
process with with OS and I'll be sure
that you see what I've got but could you
just tell me how you'd like me exactly
to proceed from here date wise and all
that uh we're we'll be doing this again
next Wednesday okay so you would plan on
executing it in a week I believe I have
this is an early bill so we have to
execute the following week yeah so again
that's why we're doing getting the
groundwork set today okay now when said
are you all set with this is this this
work for you before I take yeah so as
you recall the department did not take a
position on this bill we did express
some concerns in the first hearing um
this is obviously a lot of changes and
proposals have been talked about today
that will presumably go into and a
proposed Amendment and so I'll be
coordinating with our leadership to
figure out where we're going to be on it
but I think this this I would observe
that this addresses a lot of the
concerns that we had about
implementation of this okay so it's it's
going in the right direction but you
haven't got their blessing but as far as
you know this we've we've we've turned
over enough rocks I think that's a fair
statement yes yeah I just have a
question for you Mr W um budget time
when it comes budget time will you be
including this position in your budget
yes if this bill were to pass then
presumably it would be signed into law
um in the in the in the summer and
that's when we start working on our next
Bal budget so we would uh certainly uh
you know with armed with that knowledge
we would work that into our budget
proposal thank
you okay yes I just want to make sure
we're aligned in this and and as long as
the Director is sitting here if I'm
preparing this with OS when would be the
effective date
that you'd like to see for the hiring of
the employee so that I don't put a sun
just thinking in here that is wobber jaw
so to
speak so if I understand your question
the the bill is it's currently crafted
establishes a position in the department
and it
um appropriates the salary and benefits
and other costs associated with that for
the bium ending 202 five which is our
current bium um so ideally we would want
to see I mean in order to get a good
running start and get
the all the necessary infrastructure in
place to administer this it would be
helpful if this position were effective
um I I mean realistically in terms
of if it were created and it were
effective uh say January 1 of
25 that would you you know if it were
signed in the summer of 24 then that
would give us time to get all the
Personnel work done through the
department of personnel get the position
posted and then hired in time for a
start date in January so you think
that's a good date well the way I read
it yeah I mean that's what I saw the
2025 yeah right yeah I think that's F
about that is if we put a five set sun
fiveyear sunset on it that's only two
years after the ban takes place right or
am I wrong respect to be clear as I
understood what the chair said the five
years would run starting after the date
of the ban which would put us out to
2013 which I think is ample time I
thought that was very generous of me it
is you're you're you're very magnanimous
today okay now I'll open up to the
committee does anybody else have
anything else they want to participate
representative
hmond uh so when that fiveyear Sunset
comes up how will the legislature
evaluate whether or not to continue what
are the metrics that we could look at if
if anybody has ideas on
that go ahead if you if you want to I I
would I would presume that uh the agency
would report on the success or of you
know really you know evaluate the
success of the program and also the
workload associated with the continued
administration of the ban and then uh
make a recommendation to the I mean
I'm not be honest I'm not entirely sure
how that would happen in mechanically
but from our perspective we would
evaluate you know what what uh personnel
and labor load implementation and
administration of the band was imposing
on us and determine whether you know we
might come back and say it's working
great a lot of states are on there isn't
a heavy load we could we could do this
with a part-time position or we could uh
you know incorporate it into an existing
position or you know we report I was
kind of hoping it'll be like Mercury
where we don't need any position sure
that and we would hope for the same
thing sure I had a thought um if if you
folks uh would like something in the
bill that asked the agency to come back
and report in five years on the program
I don't think I mean I actually kind of
like that idea I don't want to burden
you guys any the idea of the sunset is
to force that conversation to occur yeah
rather than put any sort of report Lang
they would have to come in and say and
talk well so the other the other uh
response I was thinking for um
representative Ammon is that somebody
then could propose a bill to extend the
position and then you could have the
conversation as part of that either way
um bill that's exactly why I suggested
the sunset I I you are kiding okay okay
represent yeah thank you for that uh I
so when you said the word success I
guess I was just trying to foresee how
do we measure success uh other than the
workload for the Department Ju Just so I
have in mind if we're talking about this
in five years you know what we're
looking for I I I think our measurement
of success would be you know we've got a
person working on this and they're doing
compliance monitoring and and
appropriate enforcement are they large
Su a great success would be they do this
compliance monitoring and they really
find that all the all the banss are
being complied with and they need to do
very little enforcement um you know
moderate success might be most it's
mostly complied with but we have to do a
couple of enforcement actions each year
for a particular product and then report
to the legislature on that you know and
also how much labor I mean how much time
do we really need to log um of a
person's you know time uh on an annual
basis to to appropriately do this
compliance monitoring and
enforcement okay Mr chairman oh yes re m
u thank you you just a real quick
question one of the things that you said
is that uh to test a product you had to
buy the product and bring it back to a
lab is there an instrument that you can
scan a product and and it will reflect
whether it has a past or not um that's a
great question and I'm not sure about
that for p i mean the analysis and the
and the technology associated with
analyzing for past is advancing every
month because so many people are working
on it and doing inst there's so much
time and money being spent on past I
will tell you that in in our products um
uh Tex and packaging uh work we actually
there is a handheld device called an
x-ray uh U an xrf an x-ray defraction I
think it is um that uh um that quickly
and cheaply in in real time measures
Metals concentrations and we've used
that to scan packaging in the past if we
find that we think that a particular
package doesn't meet the requirements
for a given toxic metal we would then
take a samp purchase and Sample it and
send it to a lab because in order to do
an enforcement case you got to have
reliable laboratory data so there are
examples of that and whether that exists
for past right now I'm I I doubt but
it's certainly possible in the future
could
exist thank you very
much any other questions in the
committee members seeing none thank you
uh can I just ask yes so with within one
week next Wednesday we're going to see
another amendment and that's when we get
to vote on it again maybe maybe we'll be
ready maybe we won't but we'll try to
get theoretically we have all our you
know issues have been addressed just
want to make sure thank you and make
sure that exemption list is nice and
long right and if I may my former
chemistry professor would be ashamed of
me it's xway for fluoresence that's what
xrf stands for there we go well I was
just going to say I'll I'll I'll work
with um the toxicologist to try to come
up with a definition that works um even
though I will hate it regarding uh hfos
yes that I know you hat you have I said
that yes you made it perfectly
clear all right thank you all right
moving right
along uh
1674 establishing the new legal tender
act in saing estate bullion
depository so my question to you is that
you people if they have this thing
exists aren't they going to be using
digital technology to pay
bills and isn't that exactly what you
don't want up there in that government
Central Banking digital currency so
we're going to start there yeah answer
that question for me so I I so I have a
clear understanding so this has to deal
with tokenizing real world assets
tokenizing sounds like tokenizing real
world assets just remember that phrase
because this committee if if this is the
domain uh the subject matter committee
for uh for currencies like that right
right we're GNA have to understand all
these things so tokenizing real world
assets gold would be a physical asset it
would be held in a depository right um
and it would be audited to make sure
that the tokens issued the receipts the
digital receipts for or your deposit are
backed by the are backed one to one
right and redeemable for and because
that's on a blockchain it's open source
so that's the key difference between a
central bank digital currency which
would be closed source that the
government could change at any
time uh the the token Blain now we're
issued on the blockchain open source
open source and that's the difference
because you can trust exactly what it's
doing that's the key word that I and I
do know that right now do know I do know
about it but so here's Here's my thought
on this bill it's not ready for prime
time I'm going to admit that to you um I
don't think I don't know I think about
half of the business subcommittee was at
the hearing and so what I sent out
yesterday I know it's a lot to digest is
a transcript of the entire hearing um I
sent that to the whole committee I have
a couple copies here we probably don't
need to look at it this minute but I did
I used AI on the transcript and I said
list all the pros and cons and who said
those pros and cons so that's the first
page that's your executive summary of
the transcript it says who said it if
you want to go find that person and and
read exactly what they said um so I
really liked this when you sent this to
me and I was reading it over it was
great so so maybe we can punt until next
week and have a little more discussion
about it and uh and save some time today
then you'll be ready for inter room
study
okay yes I'm I'm just fascinated but
representative ad about the AI par I I
know this is probably unrelated how did
you feed in the information and then and
do it how do you do that you just
scanned it all in AI is very uh
intuitive it it's not very it's not
intimidating to try it no I refused A
yeah yeah so you can upload documents
and then ask it questions okay so you
uploaded it and you can give it
instructions and you can say that's you
can say uh that's that's good but
improve this area you know and holy
it'll it'll it'll it's like an assistant
that you can uh right we saw the one we
we had was it when we said bill it said
invoice
that all our house bills were house
invoices especially and what was the one
for representative what did it say to
change change us represented to be with
consultant or something or yeah it was
like yeah a bill was an invoice and it
was just trying to avoid copyright law
that's
represent so I looked through this bill
quite a bit in quite a bit of
detail and having written we're going to
talk about this next week understand
that but in in light of people talking
about it I would like them to understand
some of the things that I found and to
see where I'm coming from on this
because I have spent a lot of time on
this I've seen preliminaries of this
bill over the summer and I have spent
months on
it my first problem is two problems my
first problem is that it reads like a
statement of
work to set up a business if you know
what a statement of work is I can go
into that but but to set up a business
for which we have absolutely no legal
definition no legal boundaries like we
did with the da we passed the da bill it
was very comprehensive it was very good
it cut at least answered everything I
cared about and things I never even
thought of this thing presents no legal
boundaries problem with that is that's
our job that's what we're supposed to be
doing right we're setting up a business
we would create the and there is none in
here now it does have some things about
an open- Source blockchain except that
when you deal with stablecoin so much of
what happens with stablecoin doesn't
happen on the blockchain the purchase of
the gold the keeping of the books the
the uh fees that are charged that's not
part of the chain so doesn't have
privacy does it I'm sorry doesn't have
much privacy
that it tell everybody anybody could go
down that much you have this the the
depository may know if you go to redeem
it but okay other than that they won't
so that part may be covered but all the
rest of it is not in the bill it says
that this Treasurer appoints a
representative to go set all that
up that's supposed to be our
job not some representative who we have
no control over and don't know what
they've done okay we have what was your
other issue the other is issue uh there
is two paragraphs at the end of this
thing this is still part of the first
issue there's two paragraphs at the end
of this thing that says the state of New
Hampshire will block the federal
government from investigating any
illegal Acts or any acts that are
happening by owners of the
wallets that are in this chain which
means we are going to act as a wall read
the last two paragraphs we are going to
act as a wall between anybody
wishing to do any kind of crazy thing
that they do these days with this stuff
and it's about A40 billion dollar since
2022 blockchains for uh I mean not
blockchains I'm sorry stable coins have
been used for $40 billion in illegal
activities so it's not something that
maybe it happens once in a while and
these things include
ransomware and all kind if you disagree
please tell me because that's not what
I'm reading there yeah I mean I think
your inter your what you said could be
one interpretation of what it says um
but it's it's not explicitly exactly the
way you put it um but that's the point
but so let me go let me just back up I
agree with you that this bill is not
ready for prime time so I guess we're
discussing whether kill it 100% or
interim study or turn it into a study
commission I think those would be the
three there but there's one other aspect
we're setting this thing up as a
business
have we done one bit of analysis that
says this state has any hope of
recuperating the money so make it a
business but those are the questions
you're posing yeah I got it those are
you'll add that to your ai ai list okay
representa
ton and and I have to ask this question
in honor of my late professor James
Buchanan who won a Nobel Prize for
this you're
you're and clarify when you refer to
bullion and tokenization of real world
assets you're only referring to gold is
that correct you're not referring to
silver or or bricks as it's it's gold
and silver you wouldn't do platinum and
you wouldn't I'm I'm asking the question
we could so so the the way I see this is
sort of like an entryway into uh the
state becoming uh you know Reserve
understanding understanding the
tokenization aspect so you can tokenize
lots of different things yeah professor
buan prize was re awarded for his work
on establishing
bricks as clay bricks as a reserve so
that would incentivize the production of
bricks which would or there was a finite
number of bricks therefore you could
limit the expansion or contraction of
currency based on the availability of
bricks because that because I could make
bricks in the mud with my backyard right
corre well you could go M gold in your
backyard it's not scarce the way gold is
but everything is relatively scarce so I
not to go down too far down that rabbit
hole and I I don't know that I think
it's a bad Bill I just want to be clear
it's a specific we're talking about
bullion as simply gold and silver not
tokenization
of other assets not Platinum but maybe
Platinum would make sense later on you
know I I don't know all right um if if
you want so there's a there's a a
discussion about the cost and I that's a
valid and the return to the investor
which in this case is the state of New
that gets to where my issue is but let
me just talk about uh the fees that that
but let me mine's really easy I'm
against the state state bank yeah this
says State depository that sounds like a
state bank to me and I'm against indate
bit I really think that there's no
there's no lending or financial services
out of the deposit it's just it's just a
a storage of the that's what my my B my
bank got out of the depository business
and now just into private wealth let me
just talk so I this should best be done
by a private Enterprise all right so
that's my we can talk about that next
week I I have an amendment that does
need some work but what it would do is
create like a licensing scheme for the
state if somebody wants to go and do
this as a private business I would be
more I'd be more attractive to that
concept than having the state involved
if if I could if we're going to talk
about it um so in the digital asset
space there there's the idea of a
sovereign uh giving its uh stamp of
approval its guarantee on a digital
asset would give that uh would create a
a trust in that asset in the in the
digital economy right most likely yeah
um but if you wanted to look at so
tokenized gold is about it's about
there's about 10 million of tokenized
gold it's not very big transferred every
24 hours okay so if the state got 10% of
that that would be 1 million every 24
hours right potentially I'm just giving
you a rough estimate and that's
$365 million a year if we if if the
token extracted a 1% fee from each of
those transactions that's about 3. and
how many people do you need on that
chain to achieve that how many investors
do you need in this thing have you done
that analysis has anyone done that
analysis I'm just saying like
potentially if those tokens were traded
it could be a source of revenue for the
state how do you start it up is a is a
big question I don't have the answers
for that so but that's the thing without
doing that without doing that analysis
don't pass that don't pass this every
time we see the state bank they always
say this will be a good economic thing
for the state to getv but you can see
those metrics now like in the open
should should the state be in the
Cannabis
business have we moved
on I think we're moved on yes can I ask
a
question
yes
um representative Amon what what is the
Practical purpose of all this I I it
seems to me it's sort of an ideological
type of thing as opposed to it should be
um I can tell you how I I think about it
if you yeah let's let's do that next
week we can do it next week we'll do
that yeah put on your list of things to
discuss I I'll talk about $34 trillion
in debt and how the interest on the debt
is surpassing the military spending
that's my okay
all right last but not least
establishing a condominium dispute
resolution
board okay anybody want to weigh in on
this
one we're not taking testimony but you
can certainly sit there if anybody has a
question
what right so you have an amendment for
this bill you have an amendment for this
bill
is okay if you want to have that in
public record why don't you come up and
say it into the microphone so the public
knows where where
you were at at
Amendment yeah but you you've been in
the legislature not long enough to know
that something's at the end of the list
that starts at 10 that that you would
not
sorry this is off uh on that committees
that have Mi decided to take we're
taking this one next and we're taking
that one after that and it's totally
unrelated to the order oh no I we do buy
things by order but okay okay so um we
wanted to put this bill into the office
of profession professional uh licensure
and
certification
on we didn't I in particular uh did not
realize that that was no longer an
option in this state because they
totally revised the offic of
professional licens certification last
year all I knew was that they had gotten
rid of the manufactured housing board
which this is based on on
FR that was Friday that I had a nice
long conversation with the people behind
you who've also been here the whole time
on to discuss um whether the office of
professional lenser could take it or not
the only way they could take it would be
if they licensed people John Hunt's rule
of
lure and they don't license people I
mean they couldn't license people in
this case nothing that would make any
sense what whatever it also would cost a
lot more than it would cost if it was
done in the model of the old
manufactured housing board which was
quite successful until it worked itself
out of a job which I would hope this one
would do but it does take about 20 years
probably uh and all we
need is a uh Administrative Assistant
but we need place for them to sit
on the Deputy Commissioner of Das is
talking to the commissioner today about
where that could possibly be I tried
first to go to the governor's office and
before the primary nobody was in the
governor's office they were just leave
telling you to leave messages and I
don't know if today's any better uh and
I
on I left left a message also for Ben
Frost of New Hampshire housing but I
don't think they're allowed to attach
anything any what Ben I think he retired
Ben Frost retired when did Ben reti last
yeah no maybe not there's another person
that is that took his place so maybe he
still he just he got kicked
upstairs he K Ked upstairs again okay
anyway so uh so therefore you're saying
at this point this
you're begging us to interim study the
bill no I'm not I'm begging you to give
me a week to try and find a home okay
sure all right fine we'll give you a and
to go back to the Department of Justice
ready for lunch you got a week talk it
out okay
thanks okay anybody else have any
questions for the the representatives
see none uh we are
adjourn
till uh
well yeah 130
sure
okay okay I'd like to talk to you more
about that
bill
started uh
so to SI
[Music]
H uh
brose
suan
Julio
Vincent
okay post yeah she's just delayed
okay uh so
1198 and
anybody have any opinions about
1198 Mr chairman isn't this basically
the same bill we had two years
ago uh that we attempted to we attempted
to do something and then the Senate
killed
it so yeah he evidently he he uh his
mother died I just saw him oh he is here
for him I just saw him is Tim Tim are
you here not here he would have been
here because SCH
for so he maybe came in and and
then that was no well that was just the
message I got but okay so all right do I
have nobody's here to present it so we
didn't present this is a well not
present it sub committee
to talk about so you don't care about no
I think we're Easter Thanksgiving
Day when never appointed and Christmas
Day we're not going to micromanage El
Comm all right nobody wants to speak for
this
bill I I wasn't here for the testimony
so is this just like right now things
aren't open on certain holidays but
Sundays are always open right we are
open on Sundays yeah right so why does
it say Sundays on
here if it's a
holiday not with any otheris law
commission may in its
discretion open provision so so
theoretically if they can't find
employees or there's going to be a
problem they might not be open on Sunday
but as far as I
know so who's working Aiden are you
working this
bill
you could take your jacket off and stay
a
while what you don't have a sports C oh
never mind of course he
does
okay are there any liquor stores that
are actually closed on
Sunday not that I'm aare of Mr chairman
Moore uh legal coordinator for the
Liquor Commission not that I'm aware of
I think uh of course on Sundays you have
Easter which is on a Sunday yeah that's
the holidays but we just want to clear
up Sunday is the question um I can't say
with 100% certainty whether some of the
stores are not closed especially if
they're in locations where it doesn't
make sense to keep them open but I think
the commission will always try to get as
much of uh sales receipts as they
can right so that was that your only
question yeah yeah I was just I thought
they were open on Sunday so I was
confused as to what the point of Sunday
is that's why I was asking right but at
the end of the day is that the
commission could have a certain store
not open on a Sunday based on the
statute the current statute the current
statute yeah the only the the bill is
just what you see that's been crossed
out
right Mr chairman question yes um so
what this bill does basically it says
that the the commission could could be
opened on Easter or Thanksgiving that's
correct or Christmas or Christmas no
less I think it's because it's not a
good idea because you sound like one of
the Senators who killed the
vill no we don't want to micro ranage
The Liquor
Commission I mean giving them the
flexibility to do it but they don't have
to do it right now was that was the
sponsor's premise that I don't see
anything offensive about that right Mr
chair no I'd like to move
itl okay repres pusc moves inexp to
legislate do I have a
second I'll second it for discussion
purposes any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate
I mean what is the logic behind it you
just don't like the idea of them being
open those days I think I think it's uh
the Press is saying that yeah that that
we're closed on Hol on the on these
three three
holidays I mean I say let the I kind of
like what Jane just said just why just
let them do it if it makes sense and if
it doesn't then don't do it they won't
do it that's my logic that's my thinking
right you're you're an
enabler yes I enable all sorts of bad
things Li en you are a liquor
enaer
okay representative
Gibs thank you um am I right that
employees willing to work on those
holidays would get time and a
half uh
they what Aiden you were supposed to be
in the seat here
don't
move I don't I want you to stay right
there in the next bill
too representative could you repeat your
question
please am I right that employees willing
to work on those holidays would get time
and a half uh for the hours that they
work on the holidays yes it it it's not
currently in the state employees
collective bargaining agreement as far
as um those holidays is and whether or
not I think those that agreement would
have to go back and be negotiated to see
whether or not there were any additional
terms that the that the union would like
to have added if they were going to be
uh told to work on Christmas or Easter
um but under the current contract if
they work on Sundays they do get time
and a
half so the current contract doesn't
provide for holidays one way or the
other if a full-time employee they would
get the same holiday pay so for example
if you're a state employee and you're
working on a holiday you'll get paid for
that day and paid for the holiday so
you'll pretty much get double pay that's
what I was going to say I thought it was
double pay and so that's can include
Columbus
Day Martin Luther King
day that's Memorial Day double time and
a
half no double time just double
time
representative
Waltz thank you Mr chairman I agree with
the other representative suan that this
is Commerce Let There Be Commerce if
they choose to open and have employees
who are willing to work on those days
why
not that's that's my well um I would say
is that uh we did pass this bill in its
current form uh and the Senate killed
it that's not a reason to pass a good
bill
there
okay
so would you be willing to withdraw your
motion uh I yes I will okay
representative
Sullivan second by representative pus
moves ought to
pass all right you own it okay you own
it you own it you write the blur you're
going to write the blur sure
okay doesn't matter either way yeah
exactly the Bill's going to die in the
Senate well unless the Senators feel I'm
sure representative selan when he goes
over and speak to it on this when the
when the hearing on the Senate side
you'll have a compelling argument why I
bet it'll be real
exciting and say it's simply
enabling um I would say that just for
the record is the S position is that uh
as much as it is enabling they really
didn't want the Liquor Commission to
even contemplate the idea of these three
holidays and and get into
negotiation with the um Union the Union
in terms of doing it or how well would
it take to get it done that uh that the
better part of valor they just said it's
that's fine let's leave these three days
as we're close those three days that was
the Senate position
gotcha you sure you still want to go go
with this motion yeah why not I just
it's not a huge deal one with the other
but it just seems like let the let the
liquor store the liquor be a business
and run the business you certainly like
to empower them to you know
well putting words in his mouth I MTH he
agreed that he was an enabler so and I'm
just saying and let and giving them
enabling them
to make that to maximize their profits
for our state let's give is their charge
you
correct okay so the motion is uh ought
to pass any more discussion on the
motion
so the I was withdrawn because you were
a very convincing representative
Walsh so now the current motion uh is to
pass so all those in favors uh raise
their
hand one
two three either way right either way
instead okay three okay all those
opposed one two I'm not uh I I need I
need someone to replace I need I have
some I need some Replacements here so I
need a replacement for post and I need a
replacement for
Vincent no actually they pair each other
out okay so then and walace is here so
which way are you voting represent
Wallace a to pass okay so that's three
for a to pass
and
um and no excuse me four do to pass
because you voted for it right because
you have one
two
three uh oh no burough I have way we're
supposed to vote burough you're on this
committee she's on yep you're on this
committee doesn't matter yes you are so
which way you want to
vote okay a to pass passes 4 to two 4 to
two 4 to
two all
right yeah because we're missing post
and Vincent yeah we're they're
paired
okay no TP
1621 I've always did pairing in the year
of the old days before they had this
replacement thing pairing always seem to
work well it works well for the Senate
this is not a political
bill it's not a polit this is a
bipartisan bill it's a bipartisan it's a
nonpartisan bill it's a nonpartisan bill
so you people could vote any direction
on it so you could go any way you want
that's right so you should all the
positions generally generally all our
liquor bills are are that way
paing doesn't no well pairing is terms
of the committee subcommittee
representation okay uh 1621 requiring
The Liquor Commission to distribute
certain information in liquor stores
don't go
far all right so you have an
amendment
yes
I'll set okay um so anyway thank thank
you uh Mr chairman members of the
committee um for allowing me to speak to
this bill um it gives me an opportunity
to fill in the gaps uh that were left
when I missed the original hearing on
this bill so um uh I I did watch the
hearing and uh my co-sponsor uh
representative priest did a very good
job without any warning that he was
going to be introducing the bill um but
there are some things I'd like to fill
in and clarify and and um first the
amendment um these were these were
issues really that came out of drafting
um it was redrafted and it came out on
the last day and and they were they were
things that I had discussed with uh
folks that helped put this together
along the way that just didn't make it
in so hopefully this amendment addresses
things um and I did see some of them
came up during your original hearing um
it it it is meant to focus on on both
Wine and Liquor any products sold at the
state liquor stores um it was meant to
include the option to distribute
information in formats other other than
the um the than than a printed brochure
But it includes a printed brochure um
and it also clarifies what the referral
resource um that that the bill speaks to
is so um I won't go through the details
of it but certainly um glad to discuss
those items um I'm just going to quickly
run through sort of a general
presentation of the uh of the bill um I
know there were some questions about
need and um the costs associated with
drinking so I'll just pull out a couple
of statistics there's one that's about
10 years old it comes from What's called
the CDC stat uh prevention status report
uh specific to New
Hampshire it estimated the cost of
excessive drinking in the state to be
$852 million um per year and it went on
to say that it estimates
341 deaths and nearly 9,000 years of
potential life lost due to um uh
excessive drinking that comes from an
alcohol related uh disease impact
database that they maintain
um uh I think you have a piece of
testimony from new Futures that also
cites that if you factor in loss
productivity the costs associated with
excessive drinking seed a billion
dollars a year in our state um and again
that was 2013 that was before the
pandemic by all estimates um alcohol use
has risen pretty much everywhere since
um since the pandemic um and Sam say uh
substance abuse in Mental Health
Services Administration
Federal uh estimates that one in 10 um
roughly one in 10 people as many as one
in 10 people uh have alcohol use
disorder um it's also true that the top
10% of drinkers or it's been cited that
the uh top 10% of drinkers consume 60%
of the alcohol sold um so basically
there's a very relatively small group of
the population that um um that we're
targeting or or attempting to reach with
this with this legislation um that
accounts for a lot of what might look
like the um you know the people coming
through the liquor stores and that's
really the the purpose behind this bill
um I like to think of it as sort of a
lwh hanging fruit kind of bill um
because it's based on a lot of things
that are already in place the systems uh
to identify refer and treat um alcohol
use disorder are already in place in the
state um and because the state runs the
liquor stores there's already routine
contact with those most in need you know
uh depending on how often they come in
you know possibly multiple times per
week of the precise people that this
would address um and the systems that
the that are the referral base and I I I
I cite in here the the 988 system in
particular
um you know are are already the the
focus of sort of broad-based marketing
efforts to make people aware of them so
this would be an opportunity to put that
information directly in people's hands
um I also sort of look at the the um
liquor commission's uh duties I was just
mentioned in in the last bill um you
know the duty of the Liquor Commission
shall be to optim optimize um
profitability of the commission and I
think this is in keeping with that um if
you look at the um concept of revenues
and excessive
expenses um narrowly perhaps not but
broadly what are called the
externalities of the transactions um are
are those costs that I just mentioned um
and they shouldn't be treated as zero in
that equation in my mind of of
profitability it really gets at the
state's overall Revenue stream and so if
alcohol is uh profitable in one sector
but causing a lot of external costs in
another sector that I think worth
mentioning um and the costs of alcohol
use disorder um have been stated mostly
born by local municipalities so um all
those cost sort of circle back around um
I wanted to mention sort of the approach
that this takes briefly um it is focused
just on the state liquor stores not the
licens vendors um for several reasons
it's a single system so everything can
happen uniformly
um it's not intrusive into uh Private
Business
operations um and it's a uh controlled
environment where where it's very clear
sort of how transactions take place um I
know there was also some concern in the
L in the original hearing about this
being sort of an uh for lack of a better
term Nanny State sort of solution um
it's actually I want to point out not
about warning about the dangers of
alcohol or or any of the things that are
sort of typically on warning labels and
other type of thing this is um this is
purely a
um uh an effort to basically raise
awareness so I lost my place on my page
but U
um to make existing resources available
to help those that that need it um
essentially um and then in terms of the
the mechanism for distribution as I
mentioned it wasn't meant to be just a
brochure it could be a brochure um but
there are other options including uh the
idea of printing on receipts printing on
packaging bags Etc um and I think the
the poster is good but the real value is
in that point of sale distribution
system um because those that have this
issue of alcohol use disorder will sort
of naturally receive this order Mo this
information most frequently um and that
sort of is the point of it uh with any
of these campaigns it takes repetition
and many touch points in order for um
that awareness to sort of uh reach the
point of action um it also might be seen
you know if these receipts or or other
materials are going home with people it
could be seen by their family members it
could be an opportunity to start a
discussion that that they probably
already know might need to happen um and
yeah there are there are um it does mean
some of this might go to uh you know
commercial buyers or outof state buyers
but I think the impact of that would be
relatively small and and you know not
wasted in that regard either so um just
wrap up um I I I did talk to a number of
groups within the state um in putting
this together um so this was developed
in consultation with the Department of
Health and Human
Services um I did speak to Patrick tuus
at the governor's Commission in
developing it I spoke with him this
morning and he said that it's okay to
mention that he's in support of this um
new Futures uh sub a testimony before um
or in support of it and again I did
speak with um a Moore from The Liquor
Commission um initially in putting this
together but I won't speak for him um uh
and it was noted that the Liquor
Commission does need legislative
Authority in my understanding to to do
things like this it's not naturally in
their scope that they can just take it
upon themselves uh to do this no matter
whether they want to or not um it can be
done uh at little cost um little
intrusion to the existing process uh you
know and I tried to make it as flexible
as possible the resources already exist
and since the state is the vendor I feel
like it has both an opportunity and also
a responsibility to to do things to
limit the um Associated harm and
Associated cost of of the liquor
industry so that's my testimony be happy
to take
questions okay well this is a
subcommittee so we don't oh okay sorry
this is this is
so when I look at it I there's some shs
and Mays in here okay and and the sh
looks like to me is that
um it has to be on the electronic
receipt or in some format yes no no not
it shall be there
and it must be on the bags now there's
no it's not it's not you know pick or
choose what your it it I just shall be
distributed to the community with each
person made at the state as part of the
printed electronic receipt for purchase
comma on the
bags or other packaging
materials so when I maybe I buy too much
but when I walk out I usually have a box
a case so are they supposed to put that
sticker on that case yeah sorry just to
clarify the way this was sent in this
this also just got drafted um it did say
Andor between those Clauses that looks
like that's not that's and or as a
separate printed item yeah so it should
have said printed in electronic uh or
printed or electronic receipt Andor bags
and other packaging Andor sep so you
would be happy that if it just was on
the receipt
correct okay that's that's something
different here okay and then um um and
on that receipt we're going to educate
them about 9
so it's two things uh first ideally
would be some prompts to make people
think about whether they themselves have
alcohol use disorder that's usually the
first threshold to someone seeking
treatment is understanding or believing
they have a problem and that's actually
some of the value of this being
repetitive um they're they
standardized uh simple sets of questions
or there's also materials I think
perhaps even that DHHS already has that
that that served that function and and
then secondly if you think you have a
problem here's the number to call right
but this is all going to be on that
printed receipt yeah I've been to CVS
yes I I know I understand the problem
with with it being on the receipt and
and I agree people or or shouldn't say
agree but I understand that people may
not read their receipts but I am
thinking if someone you know gets this
repeatedly with each of their stops uh
you know if they have a a a problem with
alcohol they these would these would
accumulate and hopefully at some point
the the information would sink in
unfortunately that is kind of how sort
of I guess what it's called social
marketing often often has to operate
okay and then the last thing is that
they need to print posters have posters
in the stores yeah how many posters it
looks like it only has to be one it just
says yeah as many as you'd like but one
for sure one for sure okay questions
from the
committee representative wal
may I ask a couple questions absolutely
Mr chairman thank you uh representative
do you know uh if this has been done in
any other
state I well we are I don't know about
other states that own their their liquor
so I do not know of other states that
own their liquor I know that the idea of
promoting identification of alcohol use
disorder and referral to uh treatment is
is something that's being done in a lot
of different ways but I I do not know if
any other state is doing this or or has
the mechanism for the
question so do you know is there any
data that has been collected by any of
these groups whether it's new futures or
anyone else that can
substantiate people that have said oh
you know what I saw this on my receipt
or I saw a poster and so it changed my
habits of buying alcohol I mean is there
any kind of data that substantiates that
because there is still a cost to this to
doing this and it seems that the cost
might be somewhat
nebulous
because it doesn't seem like their firm
cost and then and then if there's no
advantage to doing this then we're going
to keep spending money year after year
after year I mean I I think I would like
to see something some type of
measurement going on to see if some of
these whether they're automobile
accidents or whatever goes down because
this was instituted otherwise we're just
spending this year after year after year
and it's like a feel-good thing but is
it actually doing any anything for
anyone
so you can ask you can ask a question so
so let me answer that question then I
I'll take the other one um so the there
are there are sets of um
scientifically validated questions that
um have been tested to help people get
to the point that they recognize that
they have alcohol use disorder I didn't
specify you know that it has to be um a
scientifically backed set of questions
or anything in here but I would assume
working with Health and Human Services
they're they're well aware of that but
um I can provide if you'd like some of
the information that shows that these
questions exist and have been scientific
Al developed in order to help people get
to a place where they would consider
using treatment so um whether or not and
the thought of an evaluation did cross
my mind when I was putting this together
um I decided it didn't really belong in
here probably the best place to do that
evaluation would be through the 988
system or through the referral system to
basically perhaps add a question have
you seen that material did that have
anything to do with your um but that I
don't think is in the purview of of this
bill because it deals specifically with
the Liquor Commission not with the not
with the referral resource but I do
agree to your point you know we don't
want to do things that are not
effective okay
repres thank you Mr
chairman is it is it safe to
say
that it'll cost a dollar per transaction
if you averaged it out because some will
call the 988 line and take you know use
some Services some will just throw the
paper away a lot of people in between I
mean is it safe to say that you think
it's about a buck each time I I I just
I'm not in a position to answer that I
know if it's done through the receipts
you know the cost to The Liquor
Commission hopefully would be fairly
minimal um the cost of the entire
transaction if someone has a problem you
know goes through because the 988 system
already exists it's not being set up you
know I mean the cost to actually get
someone into treatment for alcohol is is
is high but it it has you know those are
also proven treatment modalities for for
alcohol uh so you know this is a very
small cost upfront to sort of hopefully
make use of systems that have already
been developed that have larger costs
associated but are basically goals of
the state in my understanding so 10 or I
mean 10 or 12 million doar in
referrals and expenses and printing I
mean as written it's multiple things but
you you'd be fine I think you mentioned
changing it to only printing a alcohol
is bad I mean sorry to over simplify but
on on the receipt a small message on the
receipt yeah so the the amendment
basically says it's at the liquor
commission's option how they distribute
that information either printed or
electronic um receipt or on packaging
materials or on um or on uh a separate a
separate item but yeah I I have no
ability to to comment on the associate
question would be is U would you be
happy if all they did other than the
posters if all they did is printed on
the receipt yeah that was specific
conversation I had with the groups I
mentioned devel the least least
expensive least because to print out
little cards because like you say the
the going on the packages and bags and
that would be that would open up a whole
can of worms you know in terms of you
know some people buy uh especially at
holiday they have things come in a box
is that is going to be on that box so
that would mean they would E A have the
pre have a sticker on there which of
course they won't want to do that
because that would kind of ruin the box
for Christmas but but the more
importantly is is to have that piece of
paper if they can avoid having to worry
about giving any piece of paper that the
computer would automatically generate
this
message then you would be happy yeah and
and I will reiterate that what I said
during the testimony that that the
estimates of the direct cost to this the
state through all of the um I'm not
worried about that 988 is exists you
know we we if anything you can do to
drive more people to 988 that would be a
good thing right right and I was just
weighing it against the sort of estimate
of $832 million a year in other costs um
that that are associated which is in
excessive I think the total liquor sales
if we just cut this thing down to a very
simple thing printed on the receipt yep
I I would be very happy we are not doing
that today you're not worrying about all
the other all the other places okay now
representative wals you have a response
to
that somewhat I just wanted to add that
my quick lookup shows there are seven
states that own uh all the liquor stores
so it may behoove you to find out if any
of the others do anything like this so
it's Alabama Idaho New Hampshire North
Carolina Pennsylvania Utah and Virginia
yeah I did not I did not do that that
inquiry as I thought there was I thought
there was more like 16 or 17 states
there are there are follow there are
other more that states control
distribution same thing yeah okay yeah
and I wasn't saying that I know that
they don't I'm just saying I didn't look
that they did yeah representative pusc
uh thank you Mr chairman um let me
preface my
remarks uh by saying that I agree with
new
Futures that is a practical
compassionate perspective and the bill
is good
policy
but I see this as the nose Under the
Tent that this will become a State
program and the quarter to half million
dollars will rise
commensurately uh there I know new
Futures has programs where they have
these types of things and I'm quite sure
that the Liquor Commission would make
room in the facilities for any any
entity that would want
to uh agree with new Futures and put in
anti-alcohol
information so uh although I love it I
have to vote against
it okay uh was that a question or just a
this is a subcommittee so you're he's
entitled to his
opinion was not a question I I will say
it's not about alcohol or discouraging
alcohol use it's really about treatment
and referral okay represent Ammon and
then repres I'm not on the subcommittee
but I did have a thought to throw out um
we've seen bills in the past that want
to ban the printing of receipts
altogether unless you ask for it so
we'll just have to keep in mind if those
bills come back that I think that would
impact the this uh this idea okay and it
does specify it can be printed or
electronic
receipt that's great but we don't have
that yet okay represent yeah you take it
I think if they if it's printed on the
receipt I think that's fair because I
think they can add you know probably I'm
not sure but with very little money they
can add another line item or another you
know phrase or a couple words on the
receipt and the posters um um can be
probably produced by new Futures so that
wouldn't you know that wouldn't uh cost
The Liquor Commission you know any money
but if you have it on the receipts you
can't have have the um um person running
the cash register um asking if you want
the receipt or not they should just give
them the receipt anyway instead of
asking because the the receipt is
printed anyway so put it in the bag
don't even ask do you want the receipt
or not because every time I go do you
want the receipt or most of the time I
just say no I don't need the receipt so
I think on the receipt I think that
might be doable uh and maybe new Futures
can you know produce a poster in
conjunction with the liquid commission
to make that work one per store would
you believe yes okay representative Sol
yeah I'm just curious if it's where this
um these expenditures from the fiscal no
come from just because if it's going to
be on a receipt it's hard to IM
imagine maybe a quarter of an inch more
paper half inch more paper is going to
add up to a half million dollars um do
we know where that came from or yeah
well Aiden's here and it's his fault
anden and I believe he was looking at
the brochures he was looking at the
original Bill the brochures and the
handouts and all the printing of all the
and then he was looking at the amount of
transactions and numerically came up
with this outrageous number due to there
are so many transactions that look store
which we would be handing them that
brochure that piece of paper that makes
sense so yeah I think if if we're
talking about just the receipt thing
this isn't particularly concerning from
a cost perspective is my guess correct
me if I'm wrong or a different opinion
and I mean do I think this is going to
have a huge impact my gut says no but I
can't imagine it's going to be a
particularly like negative impact or big
cost so I mean I don't I don't see a
particularly offensive thing about this
idea just sort of my
take yes represent pelli just a comment
well I think this is well-intentioned
there's alcohol there's gambling there's
drug abuse these are all very worthwhile
areas where we want to get the message
out but I'm going to ask you I'm going
to charge you with thinking differently
about how we communicate to probably the
target audience that you're looking to
uh make sure they understand this
information is available and a receipt
is not going to do it the Liquor
Commission does a phenomenal job in
marketing
uh please ask them how they think they
would be able to better communicate
through public service announcements
social media different methods of
communication that would really get the
message out would probably be negligible
in cost and might be more effective than
a receipt that probably no one would
look at so I'm going to ask you to
please work with the marketing
department of the uh State Liquor Store
that does a very good job in uh getting
their message out and see what other
types of communication that would be
zero cost and be more effective okay
yeah just just to Circle back on on that
um you know the the state already puts
resources into promoting 988 through
other mechanisms you know and as I said
those are not targeted as this would be
those are broad-based um you know and
and uh there are there are resources put
behind that um I you know I would love
to work with them on this but that's
probably not going to be my role my role
is to sort of introduce the legislation
um and I did sort of explicitly leave it
in the hands of the Liquor Commission it
says working with the Department of
Health and Human Services to figure out
how best to communicate that but um I
think the the the key was some way that
each time someone comes in because the
people who come in the most are the
people with the most need for this
information um this would almost
naturally target the population yeah
okay I'm going to move this along a
little bit um because we've kind of
narrow it
down and uh as much as I think new
Futures would love to to distribute
posters but we were not that's that's no
we don't want to go
there already has posters
thereon there are posters Flyers free of
charge to the commission or anyone else
until they have them now and they have
them now they have them now okay so so
that is only as good as that anybody
reads those posters having said that um
I I would say if we were to narrow this
bill to Simply on the
receipts because no human has to be
worried about it right Aiden
would good come would excuse me let
Aiden L thank you very much for your
speaking L thank thank you for allowing
me to speak
yeah Mr chairman I think it it might be
appropriate where there are so many
different moving Parts in this bill that
um maybe if you if the committee were to
give us time to go back to the
commission talk to the chairman uh about
what the capacity is I I I don't know
exactly what it would take no I I'm not
asking you to commit for the yeah the
commission I'm just I'm proposing now a
concept that we narrow this bill to
just the
receipts and just that we really want to
do is educate people about
988 I am always amazed I mean we had a
member of the committee she didn't even
know 98
existed I think that if we narrowed it
to just 988 I think this would be a
perfect amendment to add to our
marijuana bill that cannabis bill which
also has could have
state stores and we wouldn't want it to
be printed on their receipts too that
988 is nothing else if we educate people
that 988 exists that could be a good
thing I'm now so I'm gonna thank you
Aiden so I'm now going to bring it to
the subcommittee how do people feel
about
that compromise a simple amendment to
this bill I think it's good just like
one you're in well just one line or
something it'll be a minimum line it
just you know but it'll be you know
something to say that you know that that
uh you know about 988 and that it exists
and and feel free to call it when you're
maybe think thinking that maybe you
really should have it if you are
drinking
or
smoking we can't go there yet or buying
lottery tickets or Lottery T lottery
tickets we
can I don't think you get a receipt with
a lottery it's free of charge uh
what that they're already posters now
that are already being distributed
they're already there in the store
they're in the liquor stores no oh you
said there was no they're available
okay sure come on so what you're looking
at Mr chairman is taking the amendment
that you have and taking everything
after electronic receipt for the
purchase period and everything else is
struck yeah pretty much
y good afternoon Kei FR from um new
Futures this was in my testimony so I
just want to clarify it and um Jenny O
Higgins from the Department of Health
and Human Services was going to so oh
I'm sorry was going to be here today
Jenny O Higgins from the Department of
Health and Human Service is going to be
here today there is a campaign out that
has been um Department of Health and
Human Services has spent a lot of money
on strong as Granite campaign that the
idea is a full immersion of information
about 988 and that information through
posters social media so the what I was
trying to say and had in my um testimony
is you could get multiple posters to
distribute to The Liquor Commission free
of charge um they are available
completely already
think from the discussion if if they
were mandated to do it be a lot easier I
was just talking to Aiden if it's
something that they'd be willing to do
that's even easier I'm telling you they
are free of charge there is no cost
anybody can order
Flyers uh wallet things anything so the
information is there and it is exactly
as you said chairman it's information
how to contact it's 988 very simple very
simple okay so but I I'm sure
and now I'm gonna now I'm going to look
at you
mark that that the Liquor Commission be
more than welcome to accept these signs
and get them but I know you're
enforcement so there's no one here
actually from the retail side of the
division to carry on this uh that we'd
love to see some 988 signs you know
poster
yeah make that happen Okay I hate to
clutter the statute with that but any
okay repesent pus thank you Mr chair uh
I would you believe um would you believe
that print stock roles can come
pre-printed on the back in red with all
these messages and we don't have to
print them on our uh
terminals unfortunately that that is
true they could get those pre-printed
rules but yes thank you I'm sure but
right now we're just trying to get the
computer to operate on the front side
get that
right okay so that would be Amendment
and we'll take up this uh Bill have this
in a week we'll have an amendment drawn
up
and all right all right that's good yep
okay all right last but not least
1633 so theoretically in front of
everyone
okay oh there is a fiscal number I don't
Knowle the amendment but I got it
yesterday
two yeah it's a different yeah okay be
two but technically it's the latest one
what you want me to do oh I won't worry
about it okay okay thank you you have
copies for everybody cop okay go ahead
and just trip just Tri it I I hate to
Hate to kill all those trees and not use
it okay all right so what's happening
right now is um in front of everybody is
an amendment um that
theoretically uh was drawn from the
notes of the Cannabis
commission all right now I assume that
very few of us in this room who actually
read this cover to cover and absorbed
all when did it come out five minutes
ago exactly exactly exactly all right so
I don't think we should discuss it
because we don't that's can I finish my
sentence thank
you so what I would like to have a
discussion on now is in terms of what we
do for next
week okay okay and the question is is
the committee um willing to look at an
amendment that is
theoretically um what the Senate has
verbally said to me that they are
interested in in passing
or deep sck it don't care pass the bill
in its current
form and see what happens when it gets
to the Senate so that's what we're going
to discuss right
now so evidently uh representative buo
you have strong opinions about what you
think we should do can we have the
sponsor come
up the chair and talk about what we're
talking about right now well this is
really a subcommittee decision about
whether we want whether I mean I think
we all know what the sponsor wants she
wants her bill right but everybody else
oh oh oh you might want to speak towards
this amendment I'm hijacking her bill so
she needs to speak on the bill that's a
way to look at it hijacking
okay she asked me to do a non- gerain
Amendment hearing which I'm agreeing to
do so I guess what would you rather us
do would you rather us not have that
non-domain hearing and just go ahead and
discuss your bill or are you interested
in passing or just uh in really passing
the ultimately we don't want to waste
our time uh passing this amendment which
is based on upon the
commission's uh report or actually not a
report because didn't put I guess they
did a report but what the commission's
work was um so the reason why we put
this bill together in the first place is
because we weren't sure what was going
to happen in the commission we knew that
legalization is a topic that's very
important to the people of New Hampshire
so we wanted to make sure that we had a
path forward that had already reached
some agreement where we could look and
see what the possibilities would be um
listening to the commission and
everything that happened there's I know
there's a lot of interest in having a
state-run model but there are multiple
ways to have have a state run model and
I think that we can come to something
that meets most people's needs while
making sure that we're minimizing risk
to the state so one of the big issues we
have to face is the fact that uh you
know you probably remember McDonald's
and the hot coffee so McDonald's had
their franchisee who served coffee that
was very hot it spilled on somebody's
lap it burned them and they sued not
just that franchisee but the franchisor
McDonald's corporate so we should really
be careful as we draft our state run
model to make sure that we don't turn
New Hampshire as a state into McDonald's
corporate and make us liable not for any
just problems with the Cannabis but if
somebody slips on ice on their way in I
know that there's different limitations
and especially if it is a state store
there may be a little bit of wiggle room
but we want to make sure that we're not
creating a franchise underneath the
state so there's three tests that are
used in law to determine if it's a
franchise the first is using a trademark
I think just about every process that
we've had has some State recognizable
symbol for cannabis the fact that this
is not federally allowed and that each
state has their own market and it makes
sense that each state sort of has some
marking to that it's New Hampshire
cannabis or California Cannabis or
Massachusetts cannabis makes sense and
Most states follow that so anything that
would be sold in the state of New
Hampshire would essentially be under New
Hampshire trademark so we're already
meeting step number one step number
three is is that the franchisee pays the
franchise or a certain amount of money
to do that that can either be in a fixed
amount that they're paying to the state
or a certain amount on sales so the fact
that if we're going to look at either
rooms meals cannabis going to look at an
excise going to just look at at
licensing fees based on the volume that
come through the door anything we do
that makes it so the state of New
Hampshire can benefit from the money
that's already being spent out of state
on this product is going to meet section
number three so we're already going to
meet one and three we need to look at
section two section two talks about how
much operational control the franchisor
has over the
franchise so if you're going to have
something where everybody's driving up
to a McDonald's or a Chick-fil-A or
whatever the standard look is that's
giving a lot of operational control to
the state um even if you talk about the
way that they do marketing and have the
marketing done by the fr the state that
is a franchise or
relationship but if it's only limited to
the health and safety then that that
doesn't create that substantial control
that's clearly the role of the state and
that would not make us a
franchisor my Big Goal here is to make
sure that we meet the people's needs
which is to legalize cannabis but also
make sure that we aren't potentially
putting you know State records State
funds state assets at risk because we
inadvertently set up a system where the
state's going to be on the hook so I
would like to work with you to find a
way to to sort of weave that that weave
that path square that Circle and find a
way where we can have a state-run model
that meets all of our needs while
drisking this by taking away this risk
that the state is going to be sued so I
want to work towards it it's not going
to be my bill it's not going to be your
bill but let's work towards towards
figuring out where the appropriate line
is because quite frankly if my name is
on a bill where we're talking about
being a franchisor and the state's going
to be going to be sued I'm going to have
to speak against that because
how do I know that I'm not going to be
one of the first people named in the
lawsuit when I P if I brought this bill
forward that makes the state liable you
know and and I see I see that you're
looking that I might be searching for
problems and my job on Wall Street was
to look at risks for companies for
Industries for devices and surgeries and
see how companies could mitigate those
risks to be a good investment so my job
was to be paranoid and they paid me
really well for it and also not to be
overly paranoid because I'd lose money
and then people would punish me so to
walk that line of appropriate paranoia
and I think that we need to make sure
that we do not check box number two and
we limit it to just health and safety
aspects which really are substantial so
wouldn't it be true of our liquor stores
so with our Liquor Stores um there
you're you have the stores that are
there you have that branding on the
outside right um but it is but it's not
a separate organization so if you had a
statun cannabis store where the run
store was plant touching then it would
all be within that but I know that
there's other risks that's why 1598
didn't move forward because there was
the concern about having actual state
employees growing the cand no State
employ no state employees involved here
but there are at the liquor store that's
why it's not a franchise or and
franchisee it's all just one Corporation
okay so let me just walk you through
this so you understand how we got here
okay and that was the Governor said that
um he felt more comfortable if we did
something modeled off of our state
lurker
stores and why did he say that well
because there are less stores we control
the marketing control the
advertising we don't have which I have
in my neighborhood of Massachusetts the
bud Barn that have a uniform name on the
outside that's where the where he he was
going with
it the problem with us with our state
liquor stores is that we built those
stores we paid for them millions and
millions of dollars to build that
out
so thinking Minds put their heads
together and say how do we avoid that
problem how do we get these things
created still be State managed State
marketing state so that all the receipts
are going to look the same and maybe
have 988 written on the bottom of them
okay how are we going to do that without
having to pay millions and millions of
dollars to build out and that's how the
franchise model was invented franchise
model I and I have to said I'm not an
expert I'm not a lawyer even though I've
been accused of that many times being on
this committee but I want to assure you
that franchise liability an extent of
liability in terms of whether it was the
franchise or the mother entity that owns
the franchise in terms of liabilities
are well sorted out huge amount of case
law and sving that issue so it's really
not a problem the point being is do you
want the marijuana legislation to pass
this year I want to have agency stores
by having an agency store model instead
of a state-run store model we have a
framework that already exists within the
statutes that is within our Liquor
Commission that is within the process I
recognize that currently those are only
in rural areas but by doing that it
would allow us to have a path to have a
guiding hand without controlling the
day-to-day operations because within the
health and safety that is that is the
role of government to be involved in the
health and safety but the marketing is
where you start Crossing into that line
there's you know there's also an issue
too that are we building something that
actually will have the consumers stay in
state or on their vacation shop in state
while they're here and consuming in
state or are people going to continue to
cross the border to um to show to like
qu frankly is the builtup demand in New
Hampshire the only reason marijuana
miles exist is because we're an island
of prohibition surrounded on all borders
including Canada of uh of adult use
stores so the marijuana mile issue is
less of an issue once we actually
finally enter that market because we
don't see grocery stores well we see a
couple because of our lower tax rate but
there's not a huge concentration of a
bunch of stores right over the border
from other states when we have similar
products available in both um but
getting back to the idea of having a
model that's state run we can't do the
liquor stores as the state stores
because you're right the construction
costs are high you're going to need to
figure out how to get the location I
know how hard it's been to get a really
really nice liquor store in Dairy
there's quite a few people who are very
happy they don't have to drive to
londonairy unless they want the greater
selection so thank you for helping with
that but it's a whole process too that
we want to make sure that if we do this
it solves the issues of it not being
legal in the state right now and doesn't
create new issues and um I think that
the state agency store and pursuing it
along that having a small number that
initially roll out and then sort of a
phased roll out program so that there be
can be some visibility and some
expectation slow steady and one that if
we start to see problems with it we can
hit the brakes I think would be the best
path forward that would meet the
governor's interest in having a
state-run model while also drisking for
us and making it palatable for investors
because just because you build it
doesn't mean that they'll come and it
needs to be a low enough risk
opportunity for them okay so you just
introduced a concept here of agency
stores and I'm not sure how many
committee members
know what an agency store is or what's
it about or how it operates we have
three we have three um two of them
actually get their product from a liquor
store I don't know if you knew that one
of them in Greenville does get its its
uh product directly from the Bonded
Warehouse which there is no Bonded
Warehouse in your
bill so in NE cases you're trying to
you're trying to take a model and say oh
let's make this work here which is not
what your bill is about at all but more
importantly here's the most important
thing that you need to understand about
an agency store not withstanding that
they're in located in places where the
liquor store said that we would never
put a liquor store because there's just
not enough customers not enough
viability the most important thing is
that they are in convenience stores they
are in other people's stores that are
selling other
products that is a violation number one
violation of what the governor was
looking for and that is is the idea that
you are buying through a singular Market
entity state Marijuana store that is
marketed by the state a convenience
store is going to be uh I think it's
Greenville Community or a market I
forget the name of the name of the
market but that it is not that defeats
the whole purpose if you think you want
to change the idea of this bill to the
individual entities being free to
advertise on their own free to Market
themselves free to have their own
name then that flies absolutely in the
face of what the government govern was
looking for now I realize that when I
say that people say well you know who
cares what the governor thinks but at
this point I do because I want to pass
something okay and all I can say to the
committee is that anybody is free to say
nope don't want to do this let's just
can it all together and forget about
marijuana this
year but I want to remind
everybody that there are going to be
some other Governors coming
forward and I know one of the
candidates used to be attorney
general probably opposed to it certainly
the other Republican candidate is
animant opposed to it because he was one
of the people who voted against it last
three
times so if we really want to make
marijuana
happen if we this bill needs to be
amended to based upon the commission the
Senate asked for this commission the
Senate President this was under his this
was his idea that whatever comes out of
that
commission he would be more
sympathetic to passing to voting for it
so if it's important to you that we get
something
accomplished then I'm saying we need to
amend it if it's not un important if you
think it's more important that we have
individual ual
locations that market themselves do
their thing the free enterprise much
like the our neighboring states have
done okay and I would argue the reason
why they have a marijuana miles is
because those towns zoned it that way it
was all about
zoning if you want
that I'm just saying we're not going to
get it this year so that's the that's
the issue so I understand I really truly
appreciate anyone who says is no no no
no come on we're live fore or die let's
have his multiple stores all the way
okay the only other model when we take
the liquor the only other model was the
limit the amount of licenses you issue
okay because we're talking in this bill
we you know the on the amendment is you
know limiting the amount of Licensing
the amount of locations you can have
okay those I call them the taxi
medallions all right and you limit the
amount of lot of locations and I'm
pretty sure there's nobody who thinks
that's a good idea not even all those
other states that have hundreds and
hundreds of stores all across their
state okay there but I do know there are
some some states that did pass The
Medallion model okay we probably don't
want to do that it's an anathema to us
it's certainly not the way we did our
licenses when it comes to to our on-
premise and on off- premise licenses
okay so I'm assuming that's off the
table so if we really want to do this
I'm arguing this is just for humor here
I'm arguing that it's going to take
multiple years for the producers for the
cultivators to get their product growing
and make it
happen and if we were just to go ahead
and pass this limited
model and if the legislature next year
thinks better of it and thinks that
maybe we should do something
different at least you've already begun
the process to get marijuana grown in
the state because you've created the
cultivators cultivators is a free market
we don't limit those we can have as many
cultivators as you want it's all based
upon Town zoning the cultivators can
sell
marijuana will that stay in through the
that's absolutely in the bill will it
stay in all the way through or will that
be removed in the other chamber I that
was agreed to by the
commission commissioner didn't come out
with report no I let me put it this way
the commission if you if you were in the
room or watch the tape the reason why
the commission did not give its seal
approval or final approval for and
against it was that more than half of
the members refused to vote because they
thought it was a conflict they shouldn't
be evolved the the bankers I ask the
bankers well you had a seat at the table
why didn't you vote well they didn't
think it was appropri
okay so it was not to ask the commission
to take a vote was not the issue here
the issue is this is what was agreed
upon so this goes back in part to
structuring of that commission um I
think you recall that I was involved in
that Committee of conference I was
chairing it and then let you run that
process of find choosing the people that
would be part of that commission um I do
know that those who are in favor of
legalization but were more skeptical of
the state model were removed at your
request
um so that they were not members of the
commission but we still left some of the
groups that were fundamentally um
opposed to any legalization on the
commission and they voted which led to
they voted no which led to the challenge
of trying to have a commission that
entire entire point was charged around
drafting legislation for introduction
that was the charge of the committee and
it's unfortunate that it did not did was
not able to proceed through um but as
you look towards these different issues
it it's a matter of making sure that no
we're not going to have a convenience
store that is also selling it if we do
the agency mod agency model is that's
what the current Liquor Agency model is
but that doesn't mean that we couldn't
also have an amendment for next week
that would have another amendment
building off of 1633 including those
sections that are so important to people
like the ACLU about the annulments of
previous convictions because I saw that
those came out of this of the amended
version to be able to have ones that
some of the stakeholders that are
willing to do a lot of compromise to
finally reach the finish line here have
actually had their key issues removed
from the amendment um I haven't been
able to look at the entire one but I did
look at a few different key sections to
try and see what was and what was not
there uh so the idea of recognizing that
the bill that we introduced so that we
would have an option should the
commission not not come to fruition is
not going to be is not necessarily the
final path but we would need to have
something where we work and we create a
new agency model that is under that
umbrella of lior liquor but is not so
directly overseen that we are inter we
are very very closely intertwined with
the operation of what is still federally
in illegal process in an illegal
business because the Department of
Justice has stated that they they have a
law saying that they will not act on
this but that's only the Department of
Justice it's not the Department of
Commerce we had the Department of
Justice going toes licensed by the state
of Georgia and telling them to decent
assist from selling cannabis so this is
an area that's in play and we need to
make sure that even though it's state
run it's state run at an arms length so
that we have some protection um I I do
want to say that actually the city of
Rochester Maine did a fantastic job with
their marijuana mile because I used to
drive on that road to go skydiving and
it has improved so much now it is a much
nicer road to drive on it's not full of
rundown Shacks those have been replaced
with uh pretty non-descript buildings
but um when it comes back to this issue
we want to have a way where we can get a
state run we have good State control but
the state's not at risk and where it's
phased in offerings because then it's
not a taxi Medallion when there's simply
openings I mean we have this our schools
are obviously subsidiaries of the state
because they are they're they're the the
local board covering the school
districts but we still have a way that
we slowly roll out those School B
building funds we have other areas where
we roll things out on an as available
basis to the public or to other
interested parties so by having a staged
slow rollout where we can start small
with the number of stores figure it out
figure out the problems as we move
forward and then solve those in a slow
soft launch that'll provide a viable
Market while protecting the interest of
the state I think that's something that
we could come to an agreement with not
just with those of us in this room and
in this chamber but talk to talk to the
other body and talk to the governor to
see if we can find something where we
can recognize that perhaps we don't H
really have much marketing at all if
it's one of those things that people
have known how to seek out for a long
time I I have to say that most people
will be able to Google search and see
where there is a dispensary around them
if that's something they're interested
in and quite frankly I was offended by
some of the marketing that I saw at my
in-laws house in California talking
about mail order cannabis coming to your
house honestly I I'm a little I love the
free market I'm a little sketched out
about mailed advertisements for cannabis
because kids are looking at that so we
look at how we can structure this and
make sure that it's slow the Market's
there we don't need a huge amount of
advertising allowed to start why would
the state be running a campaign for
something that um for cannabis why would
the state advertise for a Fed federally
illegal
drug okay so if I understand you
correctly you have a vision if we were
to change it from franchisee to agency
store and an agency store would then pay
at the retail other words we will their
retail sales we would collect our 15%
tax at that point are you talking about
the basically the excise tax that we had
discussed on the wholesale prices that
passed through ways and Mains last year
what we have in this
bill is no tax because that was somewhat
of a touchy issue we have a 15%
franchise
fee so what you're proposing is that uh
because uh you're looking at we're going
to change him being a franchise they're
not a franchise they're going to be an
agency okay so an agency store is then
going to
collect I guess we'll have to call it a
tax but they're going to collect
15% on the sale right just like we
collect 15% here from our
franchises all right they're going to
collect that 15% tax the question is
when you say control of the store do the
do do each of their stores these
agencies can they do whatever they want
with the store can they be a bud
barn or do they have to
be a model franchise location like
McDonald's has requirements of about
what the location looks like well if
it's not a health and safety issue and
if it's not a violation of local zoning
and ordinances then that gets into the
substantial control of the business
which gets us back to number two of the
check Li check list because no matter
what you call it you don't have to call
it a franchise for it to legally be
considered a franchise under federal law
right so leaving that to the zoning of
the towns is a local control in one
where I I don't see many towns that want
to have you know Uncle Mike's Bud Barn I
don't think that we want to see
Massachusetts had no problem with that
but we're not we're not Massachusetts I
don't really I'm not really sure that
we're going to have towns they're going
to have you know Uncle snoop's uh
clubhouse he has his own brand which I'm
not sure if we'd be able to include if
it was all through the state there
actually is an example of a franchise
within cannabis there's uh cookies that
is a franchise but all they sell are
things that are not federally prohibited
they have seeds and they have the
strains that they license out so that's
not an any violation of federal law so
they have consistent products that are
available through their franchises in
different states um but I I've as I've
traveled i' gone and I've looked to see
what the retail environments look like
and it seems that people seem to
appreciate when there's a different
experience in different stores because
just just like your our liquor stores
have a large selection it's important to
meet consumer need and so that they
aren't going to the black market or to
other states by allowing a large diverse
product base to develop and not just one
that's highly Limited wait a minut out
we have all these manufacturers the
cultivators and that's a free market
there can be as many as they want and do
whatever they want I I don't understand
where you're thinking the states control
over the
retail has anything to do with what's
the product that sold inside and what
the packaging well that's true we do
have some packaging requirements I'm not
sure whether you're for or against that
but that I guess what I'm having trouble
trying to draw my mind is what are you
looking for other than calling in an
agency store rather than a franchisee
that what is it you're looking for where
the government you don't want you don't
want us to have uh the department rules
on and then which You're Expecting The
Entity need to be have a freeold they
can do whatever they want and I guess
that's I guess I would have to say I'd
have to see your Amendment you've got
1633 I'll be interested to see what you
bring us next week on what you think we
need to fix now if you're willing to do
it this way if you're saying no I want
to stick with my bill you know then then
you know we're all set okay we're you're
not going to do anything but if you
think that you're I want saying to you
is if you can take this
amendment and show me you know lay out
something that you would say is going to
make you feel better about it I am
certainly open to that suggestion I just
can't visualize what is it that you're
thinking that you're freeing up or not
uh the question does each location have
to look the same or is your idea with
the agency store it can be look like a
barn so my goal with this is so that if
somebody is injured or if one of the
franchises believes that they are they
have some reason to bring suit against
the franchise or which would be the
state of New Hampshire I want to make
sure that the entire State of New
Hampshire all of our assets and all of
our funds are not partic not potentially
on the hook and not potentially
investigated by New Hampshire law
enforcement because I'm not not sure if
that this this amendment strips it out
but in 1633 and in 6 639 that passed the
house last year it did not allow New
Hampshire State Police or New Hampshire
law enforcement to investigate the
violation of federal law if we don't
have that prohibition we might have our
state investigating our state and
freezing our own funds I I obviously I
hear you you've said that that now
multiple times I don't believe it I have
no no I have no reason why to think that
McDonald's or Subway or anybody has
these issues that you're describing but
if you are you are you interested in
working with this amendment and changing
something in this changing wherever you
think it's offensive and that you want
to change it
from being called a franchise and I
don't even know if we use that word in
here you do okay that if you want to
change it to an
agency
please feel are you willing to do that
is that what you want to do what I want
to do is start with the framewor workk
of 1633 and draw in as many of the
changes from your amendment that I
believe are the ones that we can have in
order to meet the needs of um all the
stakeholders and to be able to move
forward with that because my concern I
know that you don't share my concern no
I
don't I think that I don't I think I
think it's a red herring I like to play
poker I'm not gambling that much we to
up to hear what other people have to say
yeah sure you're really demeaning her I
mean I'm demeaning her yes she has a
great background you don't know
everything you're treating her like she
knows nothing I know I'm just say she
just said I don't you agree that I think
that that we are exposing these dist the
franchise by using this franchise model
we're exposing us to all these legal
case lawsuits no I I'm being honest I
don't agree can that is that
illegitimate for me to be saying that no
you can say whatever you want okay so
you have something well I wanted to know
if other people on in in in the room
have anything to say um actually can can
Matt Simon come up he looks like he
wants to say
something uh okay thank you
representative Gibbs has her hand up uh
thank you
um okay the word text gets people upset
we all know that um you were discussing
this before uh but this may be a
simple-minded question but if we can
have a 15% franchise fee couldn't we
have a 15% agency fee rather than a 15%
excise tax exactly you call it whatever
you want to call it that's not a problem
I think what the issue that she was
describing is the amount of
control and amount of requirements that
is in this in these this amendment that
came out of the commission's
amendment as compared to a much more
Freer model like we have with our agency
stores which they are a free to
advertise price do whatever they want
that that other words they'll have the
they don't have to we wouldn't be
mandating that they would write 988
there would be parameters I mean there
would be parameters which I think is
what we have to delineate exactly it's
not go do whatever the heck you want
well sounds it frankly it sounds like
sem anics to me but let's find out right
well I I'd like to hear what the free
market folks in this committee have have
to say yeah what are they looking for
yeah yeah
okay so who who do you want to hear from
I'd love to hear from representative
Ammon not to put him on the spot I'm not
on this subcommittee
um we just got the amendment I I need to
understand what's in the amendment and
uh whether we start with the original
Bill and fold in the amendment or vice
versa like I'm open to seeing that Pro
I'm skeptical it's going to get done by
next week but
okay represent spe you mentioned that
[Music]
um that uh people that have are now uh
you know the problems that the ACLU has
that is that people who have been
accused Forman yeah we we took that out
my understanding is nman is supposed to
be in this bill but I I don't I don't
know what ever happened if you're saying
nment has been removed out of this bill
that's what it looked like when I was
doing the comparison I absolutely agree
that analment needs to be in this bill
that was uh something that uh
representative Sullivan asked for and I
have have no problems putting analment
back in so we could put that back in yes
can you just describe that inment
piece I believe it's that you if you've
had a pass possession obviously not ret
you not didn't sell it but if you had a
pass possession requirement you could
petition the court to have it an
olded you could be a or just yeah
because at that point that point
youve we're we're not asking why you
want Anan but yeah if you if if you had
any prior possession it would be aned
and be sponged from the
records what does that have to do with
establishing a cannabis industry in New
Hampshire that's a separate criminal
justice issue uh it has to do related it
has to do with people feeling
comfortable with passing a marijuana
bill cannabis bill so it's an ornament
which some like you who are opposed to
it you probably it's an ornament yeah
you probably think well I mean I might
be opposed to that part maybe I mean but
it also might be an issue that should be
in criminal justice but you're saying
that's an ornament on the Cannabis uh
the history of this of the Cannabis
legislation it always went through
criminal justice because of that reason
um I think there's a drafting error you
said that the Cannabis cultivations
would be able to sell to Consumers but
on page three line 22 it actually says
they'll be able to sell to uh cannabis
to an outlet cannabis product
manufacturing facilities to alternative
treatment centers and to other cannabis
cultivation facilities but not to
Consumers um you were saying that they
would be able to sell to the consumers
so if that's the case I think that
that's probably a drafting error and
that would need to be corrected yes okay
so we'll correct that in anything that
moves forward yes thank you so where
where did you see that that is Page
Three line 22 it says but not to
Consumers so that language should say
say and to Consumers instead of but not
to so replace the but not with and to
Consumers yeah okay thank you sorry
there'll probably be more because I just
looked at it but I know that was one
that was very important no problem Mr
chair yes can we have Matt Simon just
wants to come up for a minute sure of
course
okay
thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee good to see you all again A
lot's happened since we spent so much
time together last year working on HB
639 um I thought I actually have mixed
feelings about a lot of this so I can't
I'm not here to tell you what to do but
I think I can share a few comments that
will be helpful in some way so uh uh
only one member of this committee was
was actually part of the study
commission so or actually two I'm sorry
but uh I think it would be helpful for
others to hear a little bit about what
the study commission didn't didn't do um
so we all went into the study commission
process expecting to talk about state
run stores and that changed uh I believe
in September when the Liquor Commission
made a presentation and introduced this
franchise model that was the first I'd
heard of it and I know this committee
hasn't discussed that at all um so in in
in brief the idea is to maintain the
control aspects of the state control
model but to have private actors uh
actually doing running the the
businesses that would be selling so I'm
not an attorney uh but I the attorneys
that I listened to and Trust said that
this model is is less likely to be
preempted than the state run stores
model and for that reason we were
willing to engage uh the atcs were asked
present unified testimony which we did
we indicated to the study commission
that we would be willing to work within
the franchise model if the bill
reflected the priorities that we've
discussed previously the main one for
the atc's was integrating the
therapeutic cannabis program with this
new program so the study commission
talked about that quite a bit and the
key Senators on that study commission
did agree uh on a few things um and and
to be just clarify I prefer the approach
in HB 639 and and in hb1 1633 as policy
I also want to get something passed so
I'm open to the idea that if there's
only one way to pass something we really
need to look at that uh but what the
study commission did agree on was um the
idea to the extent they agreed on
anything they ultimately didn't vote to
agree on anything but they they agreed
that the the therapeutic cannabis
program that the actual applying for a
card receiving a card the patient
registry those sorts of things uh would
remain with the Department of Health and
Human
Services and that the ATC is all of the
actual business
regulation uh because we were talking
about the same issue we were talking
about last year dual use the idea of
having one store where patients can go
and adults can go and uh the uh the
commission wanted to enable that the
issue was having two different
Regulators for those stores was viewed
as problematic by many people including
the chairman so we agreed uh that
business regulation could all be under
liquor if we were going to go down this
this path and uh that they would assume
responsibility for regulating the
business practices of the atcs so
unfortunately the study commission did
not finish its work I agree with the
reasons that were stated why they didn't
have a successful vote but I think
there's another big reason uh the study
commission spent two months going
through a draft of of the franchise
model and we didn't see a second draft
until the very last meeting of the study
commission the very last meeting of the
study commission we were presented with
a second draft that didn't have half of
the things that the study commission had
agreed on for the last two months so
that was very frustrating there this is
that bill with a few additions and the
additions are POS positive but the
additions are very incomplete from my
perspective if we're going to pass the
franchise model I think we at least need
to do the things that the Commissioners
agreed on integrating the therapeutic
canvas program so if you do want to purs
pursue the franchise model approach I
would encourage you to work on it as we
did HB 639 last year we emerged you know
we had 639 we had the the language of
1598 and after a few weeks we had
smashed them together into one bill bill
that everybody was actually pretty happy
with it sailed through the house and uh
most Advocates were okay with it so that
would be approach if the committee wants
to work on that I think there are a lot
of stakeholders that would be more than
happy to go through that process again
in this
committee another option would be to
just pass the bill as is and let the
Senate deal with it if you do that I'm
100% sure that the Senate will either
kill it or do exactly what we're talking
about uh work on making the amendment
actually something that that people can
support so I think this needs a lot of
work and whether it happens in this
committee or somewhere else um but
without getting into the weeds you know
as as we've expressed sorry previously
we want to build this matters I think
for two main reasons one is that the
atcs already have infrastructure teams
we're we want to help be part of a
successful roll out we've heard
testimony about New York and other St
states that decided to exclude medical
cannabis businesses and had very bad
rollouts as a result they wanted to
build everything from scratch and they
regretted it big time so for that reason
I think it's important you include us I
think it's important for the 14,000
patients who are registered for our
program because the future of the
therapeutic cannabis program depends on
us being successfully integrated into
this if we don't do that we're just
going to wipe away the therapeutic
canvas
program move aside atcs and we'll
replace you with something else so I
think we're happy to work with the
committee uh whichever direction you
want to go and so where where are we
looking at that where the problems are
well the problems are so I do
have a handout but I mean this there's
nothing in here about the transition and
the integration of the therapeutic
canvas program it's just not there the
language that was in HB 639 and 1633
regarding uh dual use certificates
remember all that language that actually
imposes obligations on the atcs to cons
continue serving patients to not Jack up
prices all of that uh that was all in
it's just ripped out of this final bill
that was presented on the last day of
the study commission so it's it's not
what they discussed it's not what
anybody agreed on but I'm confused
because the the two you know I was
yesterday one meeting and then of course
I had Co and the second meeting so but
when I got back you said ATC everything
was all
solved until we we it was solved in
terms of people who had agreed to things
that made sense and then when we saw the
draft on the last day of the study
commission that morning have do you have
the language that was agreed
to it was not drafted it has never been
drafted this was something that you had
just a verbal discussion and CU When I
every meeting I went to everything was
word going through and words smithing
every paragraph and everything but
you're saying you had agreements I guess
I have to go back and watch the tape I
or talk to the three Senators whose
votes are needed to support this from
two different parties and this was what
they agreed to
verbally everybody was waiting to see a
draft the draft never had tell me what
it is so I can ask him what are we
missing here what were the what were the
things that would agreed to you say you
have it written
down I mean I have it it was a concept
that was never drafted into legislative
language I believe I offered to try
drafting it at some point but I wasn't
on the study commission yeah but what I
remember when I had this conversation
with you my memory was you said yeah
this is what was agreed
to there are some things that were
agreed to and some things that weren't
so there a couple POS can you have that
drawn up can you write up what was
agreed to and and and make it so it fits
into to this amendment I'll just can I
inter it's obviously was agreed to
because was ex out in
the get in there wasn't agreed to struck
through in the amendment so it it had to
be from
somewhere uh just that was what was came
from the notes from the committee Mr
chairman can this gentleman introduce
himself and speak to the microphone for
everyone okay would you mind I mean are
we have we having a public hearing
or so all I'm asking for is myself
attorney Mike Mofford represents
Sanctuary ATC been working with Matt on
this for the last several months and if
I've got a document last night from your
courtesy that you write it to us right
which has words in it concerning the
atcs and their dual license and their
ability to participate with now which is
the integrated license which is struck
through so logically thinking somebody
wrote that down and that was the basis
of the agreement was that we worked on
the issue we came up with words the
words are here and the words are struck
through so you cannot pretend that they
didn't exist I I'm not as saying they
didn't exist I'm just shocked that that
it didn't make it to this document okay
because I wasn't there those days and I
have to admit no what I sent you I did
not read that was what I was given from
from the senators from what was agreed
so can you tell me what the RSA what was
the references so I can go back and look
at it and so we can make sure we get it
in to the bill if that's what was agreed
to we we would want to put it back in
the bill if it was agreed to well if you
look on page actually last night's
document page 13 okay so all right I
don't I don't have I don't have that
with me but okay so what is what what am
I being handed here what what did I just
get here it would be 318
F7 say it again regulation of candid Mr
chairman if I may uh the language that
we suggested which it's the deleted
language with a few tweaks is what's
printed in Blue on page two and three
okay of this handout I prepared this
handout this morning very rapidly the
first point is the lack of any
integration uh between the TCP and the
pro proposed franchise model that's just
it was never written it was agreed upon
Orly and never written so that that's
work that still needs to be done that's
on page on your page one that's on my
page one was never drafted into the
legislation okay I wanted to praise a
couple of things that did happen since
the study commission ended so
the Not only was this language not
present but that draft that we got on
the last day of the commission actually
included this line that you can see
crossed out in blue that says
alternative treatment centers cannot be
licensed at the same location as
franchise cannabis retail outlets that
was the opposite of what the study
commission had agreed on well that's why
it's crossed out and that's why it's
crossed out now it was not crossed out
on the last day of the study commission
when this language was presented what's
it in this bill uh this bill I was going
to praise the deletion of that line uh
it no longer says we can't be collocated
okay it is completely silent on the
subject of location collocation there's
no path forward there's no Ru making
there's nothing for DHHS there are no
changes to the therapeutic cannabis
law the work that would need to happen
to make these things integrate has not
been done the study commission did not
do it uh the other thing I was going to
praise simply because I mentioned in
testimony last week was the new in the
bill is specific language regarding hemp
derived canabo so I think we''ve made
two steps forward since the study
commission finished its efforts uh but I
think we're a long way to go as far as
specific changes to integrate the
program we can go into that if we're
going to have a a non-gain public
hearing on this uh otherwise I don't
want to get too far into details it
would be very helpful to understand
Concepts yes I I just C could you
clarify with the um the gentleman next
I'm sorry I don't know your name Mike
okay I was wonder what document did you
get that you document we received a
document last night called draft working
with edits and that was from the
courtesy of of chairman hunt right I'm
just curious why the committee didn't
get that uh I it was what was sent to me
for the commission and I I I sorry I
didn't send it out to the committee I I
thought I sent it out to everybody but
but this document shows the items were
remove I can send it to you right now I
don't we have it now we got something
from you didn't we you don't have it
okay well that's another
problem and there's somewhat of a a myth
that at the end of the commission there
was some form of agreement uh during the
whole course of the commission the
discussion of dual use certificates
participation of the atc's it was going
beautifully smoothly until all of a
sudden pop at the end day it was a
complete disaster because you had no
idea we were Sid swiped by suddenly
being swept away and and to elude that
the commission had any type of agreement
is really a far
reach Mr chairman okay so uh go ahead I
do have a question do you think it was
problem I mean I know that the
commission was open anybody could attend
do you think it was problematic that
there were not industry experts on the
Commission in retrospect this there were
a lot of issues with the commission and
that certainly was one of them okay we
had competing interests on the
commission people working desperately
hard to trip us up up at every
particular juncture and they waited till
the last day to pull the rug out from
one be everybody all I remember was when
I came back and I was starting about
what I thought where we were and you
said no no John you were gone every this
was all solved that's all I remember but
you can't blame me must have been but I
do see something Municipal zoning and or
local regulation cannot prohibit the
licensing of an integrated Canabis
establishment
I don't know how I just popped and fall
into that but how are we going to tell
the municipal what they can or can't
do well that's wonderful except no way
does it say we can have a dual use
license okay so to get down to the
bottom line is is the Dual use license
issue is that what the problem is here
or we can call it the integrated license
or the Dual
use yes that that's I guess I the way I
remembered it was that is that you would
get the regular franchise you g to take
your locations you already
had and you would then be uh submit them
to the state as and make them a
fullblown location but knowing that you
would then have to collect the tax or
the franchise fee is that did I am I
that was my understanding Mr chairman
that is not what this bill says Okay so
this bill does not say anything
about what is it so in terms of okay
the way I understand it atc's could
theoretically apply for these licenses
and cor we would be expected to wait in
line with everybody else and there is no
Ru making to explain how this integrates
with the program that we already have if
we want to have a single regulator for
adult use cannabis this bill doesn't do
it
okay it creates a new system to compete
with the existing system
okay
question yes representing you so I've
heard you both say that the commission
let you down stuff came in at the last
minute I heard you also say that we're
the committee's largely uninformed
because we weren't on the commission
you're terribly wrong there because
we're incredibly informed right it's our
job to be informed here and we are just
because we weren't on the commission
doesn't mean we didn't watch them and
read all the materials so thanks for the
joke about getting into the weeds but
let's not get into the weeds would you
age that there's a long ways to go and
if you want to make changes to this come
with the draft to the bill we're working
with now or let's send it to interim
study and get it right the the next time
during that study period so which is it
do you want to complain about the
commission not getting it right or do
you want to change this one or do you
want to send it interim study
representative I am not here to complain
we've been participating in good faith
in this process for years and we will
continue to participate in good faith
trying to create good cannabis policy
for the people of New Hampshire
if it's the will of this committee to
work on the details of this bill we'll
be here to work on the details of this
bill if you want to pass it as is we'll
work on it somewhere
else it's I don't even know how I would
vote if I were sitting in your shoes
frankly because I see both sides I see
the desire to get something done no
matter what it says I also believe
having worked in cannabis policy for 17
years that there are a lot of very
important policy choices here that I
don't feel legislature generally has a
great understanding of and uh I don't
think they're addressed in this this
bill in front of
us and I'd like to correct the record
because I don't recall ever saying you
were uninformed the issue here is again
what we had the last day of the uh
commission was we have a brand new 40
page Bill the needs analysis you didn't
it was your your colleague it was just
before you uh stood up and interrupted
the hearing so let the ra show
that
ially we're talking about when the bill
needs to be
out so
therefore I was another on
the should
we Mr chair
for we ask people if we
have that's your your The $64,000
Question is what which one are we what
are we going to work from we're not
going to work from the amendment Mr
chairman should we just pass H hb1 1633
and then the Senate can go through this
amendment process if they want I mean I
assured with un no questions whatsoever
if you send over that bill if it doesn't
have anything that look like the
commission it's Dead on
Arrival that's what the Senators tell
me I mean that maybe I they what they
say and what they do who knows but I
mean maybe they will I I think great
let's go ahead just send it up it makes
my life easier just send it all over
this is send it over there lot of time
it's not getting anywhere and I think
this is a bill that the house overall
bipartisanly just like the last one is
pretty comfortable with so I mean it is
a good message to send
and I don't know it seems like we're
just like spinning our wheels and not
making a lot of progress with this
discussion and I think if the Senate
realizes that this is actually a a
process that we or a model that we're
comfortable with in the house pretty
strongly comfortable in the house then
maybe maybe they might be willing to I
mean what they're saying now but maybe
they maybe they will change like when
they see a strong bipartisan vote again
I mean at the end of the day it was
driven by the
governor's concept of the of the
franchise so if fundamentally if you
don't send them
that then it's Dead on Arrival yeah then
he own here why why why do we even exist
but no not no come well he does he does
anyway why don't you ask the con
why how did they why did they create the
Constitution the way they did I don't
know that you can't start out saying the
governor's not going to sign it so we're
not going to pass it so that's what what
we do here I
thought I thought the Senate the
senators were going to put the franchise
model they were going to introduce that
bill then they
didn't okay so I I guess the best I can
say to them is um uh we you know that if
they if that's what they want if they
need to send us what they want is what
you're saying okay and all we can do is
send them send them whatever you want to
send them and don't be surprised that it
won't look like anything that they sent
and then we can review it at that time
when exactly right we would then when
the bill comes
back I will I will but it evidently is
in hopelessly flawed when I've just
heard is that it's got lots of stuff
like the nment wasn't in it was he I
mean it was close from the aflc mean
excuse
me what yes what were you going to say
sorry you were you were standing up to
say something Y come on up come on up to
the mic introduce
yourself at least it would have no I was
Tim Egan um Tim Egan had asked to come
up to just to say a
word thank you Mr chair thank you
committee uh for the record New
Hampshire can chair Timothy Ean Mr chair
I think we've actually made tremendous
progress today we actually see this
proposed amendment I think we've heard
from an array of the folks that have an
expressed interest in trying to legalize
regulate and create revenue from
Cannabis I think this bill shows
some
possibilities um I think I'm very
respective and and happy that the
portion of the proceeds that re would
come from cannabis to our state would
help things like pension fund liability
and education and with all due respect
to the Cannabis uh to The Liquor
Commission I'm surprised that uh a
listing of the Cannabis Advisory Board
does not have any professionals from the
Cannabis industry listed in it so I
think that's something that could be
worked on there are anman submission
there's dual licensure missing I'm not
going to repeat everything that all the
other my colleagues have said and the
reason I refer them as colleagues is for
the last three years what I have
lovingly called in my
my schedule the New Hampshire cannabis
Coalition is an array of folks from all
the organizations that have ADV invested
interest in regulate legalizing
regulating making cannabis safety I
think are very interested to try and
work together I know there's a short
window but I do know that both um folks
from the industry and the legisl tours
that have uh expressed interest who have
sponsored this bill and co-sponsored
this bill and as well as as you sir we
have an interest in making sure that
this is the best piece of legislation
that we can collectively create to
benefit the people of New Hampshire so
given some time I think we can do that I
know there's a clock that is ticking so
from which bill which which one do you
want to work on I think it's a little
bit of mishing the clay together and
figuring out if we make a pot or a bowl
or a this is going to have a lid but I
think it's going to be a little of both
so okay so representative
Ball's going to be in your court you
come up with an amendment for next week
and you make sure all those people are
happy cuz the Liquor's not
here Liquor's not here so this is this
is your room right here you bring us
something on Wednesday they're here but
they're here we know what they want
which which one are you this is your
amendment that you offered correct has
your name at the top of it that's
correct represents what Liquor
Commission what the governor and what
potential Senators that would have
influence on this version then you know
you're working from their from the
beginning that they start this
conversation from there all right are
you willing to do that I I think that
I'll look at the two find the different
sections and figure out where those
overlaps are it'll have clear road map
and sorry I live in dream and
spreadsheets and crosswalks um I will
look at both of them and understand the
different sections figure out where they
map together and then just figure out
the most cohesive way to get the
information presented in a way where we
can understand what we're actually doing
and we understand what the choices are
right um I just want to make it so that
it's all as clear and possible to see
and um as we draft that and try and
reflect all of the hard work that's
happened in this room over the summer
among the Coalition over these years and
to try and finally put this behind us in
a way that makes us all happy I think is
something that is absolutely worth doing
sounds great so you'll have something
for us for next Wednesday I will okay
and I guess I'll then ask is there
anybody else in the room other than
atc's that has anything that needs to be
changed in this bill other than agency
you know franchise to agencies and this
amendment and and making sure that
cultivators can sell and if I can just
make a request if there was anything
from the group or anybody if they can
contact me within the next uh before the
end of tomorrow with that so that I can
be just have a starting work workplace
to work from my email is on the
legislative site representative L on
okay representative walls you have a
question yes it goes thank you chairman
we don't do questions
comment um well it goes back to what you
saw stated it was the first thing I saw
that g on uh I think it's a second or
third page it talks about Municipal
zoning Andor local regulation cannot
prohibit the licensing when did that
happen I thought that there was an opt
out uh I all I know is uh theoretically
what's in this bill is that the
municipality has a vote to decide what
they can have or can't have right so
this is false so uh that seems to fly my
to my understanding correct right but so
we'll take it as it is see what it is
and send it on to the Senate and see
what they do with
it and I can already predict
it at least if they left that in there
I'll bet you the Senate would kill it
just on
that just
saying excuse me I really would like to
see that crossed out copy because I'd
like to see what it was that was driving
the I will right now find that and send
it to
everybody okay anybody
else no
yes in the day yep I just I'm with
the ex director um and I just want to
thank you all for all the time and the
effort that you have put into this
conversation
I really want I think there has been a
lot of progress made today I don't think
it's likely that we're all going to be
happy with anything that comes out of
this this is what I said at at uh
previously but I really do think it is
worth the work of this committee to get
as close something as good as can be
that is as close to being able to pass
as
possible out of this committee I I think
there is time to work on it I know we'll
be willing to work with the committee um
to get as as at the bill to a place as
as good as it can be um there were many
things that were in the version that
came out of the commission there were
many issues we had with the commission
process there were things that were left
out that we were not happy with um and
I'm glad to hear that things like the
annulment we can work on and we're happy
to provide our feedback um but would
just really urge the committee to
consider what is likely um to actually
get enacted into law because I I you
know regardless of
um the the way in which these the
existing prohibitions affect real people
in our community is serious and that's
what I bring to work every day
and it's it's just so important that we
come together and work together to get
something actually done this year um and
I look forward to to working with all
the folks in the room in the coming
weeks I know that you're short on time
um and and I really hope that we can get
to a place where we have language that
we can move forward with so I just thank
you chairman so but annulment was not in
here is that is that correct is not and
I can provide language that I can take
from previous versions and I will send
them to representative Le yep yes uh uh
we do have a question if you're willing
to it's just a comment a general comment
comment to every um yeah so whatever we
do in the house we we can only negotiate
with the senate in committee conference
on things that we put into the bill
right so we want to be we want to put in
everything that we we would like to
negotiate with during committee
conference um my other thought was when
the amendment's done if there could be a
onepage summary of the different
sections or a walk through so where
you'll understand what we're voting on
that would be
helpful okay so I've just sent it
anybody here can did you get it
Nita you got it
okay all right represent can we make
that can you make that available to all
of us
somehow former representative Ean got it
okay and just for everybody to
understand why I didn't bother passing
why I you know never thought to send
this to everyone is what I got was an
amendment to the original Bill and so
therefore in my mind it was it was
gobbly
okay
scrolling the attachment didn't come
through okay so I I I this is the
problems of trying this is why I don't
use my phone to do these things so when
I get home I'll send it to you but I
just want you to know it's going to be
goblook
because it's a an amendment that was
based on another bill different bill
number shows
tendy so
so over star it was the 639 so it was
the amendment to
639 so it was it's that's that's um so
um like I would say is if you want to
see what was in
it then this amendment that I you have
now in your hand is so but I want I what
I want to see is what did they
specifically not like and that
was didn't
correct didn't come that evidently the
attachment didn't come through
so it didn't didn't
open okay so I I again I it's trying to
use your phone as a computer is hopeless
um I actually do have a crosswalk
between 639 and 1633 that I can send to
the committee I thought it was just too
much information but now I think that'll
help merge theion out to everybody
that'd be great thank you appreciate it
so okay so we'll wait till next Tuesday
and see where we are Wednesday excuse me
actually I haven't scheduled it at
all what would you rather what would you
rather do Tuesday or
Wednesday because we have a session on
Thursday so we were just supposed to
meet Wednesday I was basically I was I
was planning on having a day for you
know a subcommittee day and then
executive in the afternoon thinking that
we we actually have some bills we're
ready to exec now because we we did we
did get some stuff so I was thinking
wday that Tuesday we would do hearings
Wednesday we would do subcommittees in
the morning the ones the three that we
have left over and then exec in the
afternoon and then thir next Wednesday
and then Thursday is I believe is a
session day
so but what Carrie sent out was
hearings on Wednesday and nothing else
oh okay well then the subcommittee will
be on
Tuesday but there was nothing about
subcommittees and what she I understand
she sent out hearings for next Wednesday
so therefore the subcommittees will be
on Tuesday and you haven't got the
notification yet because I haven't told
her thank you I we have a lot of stuff
scheduled for we we' postponed a number
of bills
but we told some people specifically
that they would be coming back on
Wednesday I and I am surprised she sent
that out Wednesday but I like you know
but what am I going to tell someone like
I could well I could tell you what if
you think that's a problem I will cancel
all those bills on Wednesday and move
them to Tuesday which one which is which
is worse I think that might be better
because look we told Karen uh uh
representative eel for instance to have
everything ready on Wednesday now we hav
told her that it's going to be Tuesday I
and this will be the second time I will
cancel everything that's on Wednesday
that you guys seem to have gotten yeah
it's easy enough and then and have that
scheduled for Tuesday so Wednesday
morning we'll be doing the three bills
that we have left over and then
Wednesday afternoon we'll EXA what we
have at that time that works and then um
and then and then we'll I believe
Thursday is supposed to be a session
day yeah I you know so okay so basically
we're we're we're getting close to have
heard all our bills so then you know
we're we're we're getting we're getting
close we're we're at least we're at
least two-thirds of the way
through we're two3 yeah the calendar
says for the next meeting is the first
of February right so that if I look at
my
calendar Tuesday it could be Monday
what's what What's
happen
um A subcommittee Tuesday would be fine
for me getting the amendment for that
and I'd be able to participate better
since I'm going to be having to chair my
committee some on Wednesday try to find
another room any room is fine thanks
little one yeah okay right no absolutely
little give give me a couple minutes
okay because otherwise I but evidently
you did send something out for Wednesday
I did so unfortunately I've been telling
everybody that we were going to have our
sub committee on Wednesday okay so I can
that Monday's free I have but you got no
we don't want to come in okay I I got
County okay so I need you to cancel
Wednesday I got that and then and then
Len and move it to Tuesday if we can if
you can find find Tuesday about sub
committee that would be Wednesday no the
subcommittees would be Wednesday morning
those three the three these are the
these three those three and then an
exact session on everything we've had
everything and then see if you can find
something for
Tuesday and then Okay calendar all right
so that so next Wednesday is the
31st so it's I'm just right not not
keeping up with the calendar it's right
it's calendars are annoying sometimes
with it no just like
time
February
did did you did you say you have to
chair your committee on Wednesday so
having the subcommittee on Wednesday
would be bad for
you yes I I will be my chairman um has a
doctor's appointment and so I was going
to be chairing some of Wednesday did we
have the subcommittee on Tuesday that's
what it sounded like or we switched it
to Wednesday think it just got that's
why I called
you okay
if in in the afternoon after what you're
already
rescheduling okay if that works
otherwise I can have somebody else step
into the role we're not exec on
Wednesday so I I was offering that I
don't mind having one less day to
draft yes thank
you
okay thank you
that